Zwei Sprechstunden.
Es ist mal wieder ein.
Letzter Donnerstag im Monat, es ist mal wieder ein Malen nach elektronischen Zahlen hier im Radio. Im Blumen findet das Chaosradio statt. Das Chaosradio ist die Sendung, wo der Chaos Computer Club und anverwandte Freunde und andere Entitäten, die sich möglicherweise auf unserer Welt rumtreiben, das Studio übernehmen und über ein Thema ihrer Wahl referieren. Und da geht es heute. Möglicherweise ist das für euch ein überraschendes Thema, weil es euch in der letzten Zeit gar nicht begegnet ist. Überwachung. Dazu begrüße ich ganz herzlich Andreas Bogk, schön genannt, Simon Willnauer, hallo und Joachim Scharloth, hallo und Anna Biselli, hallo. Von ferne zugeschaltet, wie man gerade gehört hat. Wer das alles im Einzelnen ist, stelle ich euch gleich noch vor. Bevor das damit losgeht, möchten wir kurz mit Andreas über die aktuellen Themen sprechen, die in dieser Woche auch angefallen sind. Dann geht es um Datenanalyse, weil die ganze Überwachung, die ist klar. Man weiß jetzt also, okay, irgendjemand sammelt alle unsere Daten. Und die Frage ist aber, was passiert denn eigentlich damit? Und es gibt so zwei Argumente, wo Leute sagen, naja, das ist alles nicht so schlimm. Das eine ist, ach, come on, da sind so viele Daten, da steigen die doch sowieso nicht durch. Das schaffen die gar nicht. Außerdem, wir schreiben einfach in jede E-Mail Bombe rein und dann ist das alles viel zu viel und versperren und dann ist das zu. Hm, werden wir mal gucken, ob das wirklich so ist. Und die andere ist ja immer so, na, ich bin ja sowieso nicht interessant. Also, da müssten sie erst mal auf mich kommen. Und da gibt es möglicherweise auch so gewisse Techniken, wie man so voll automatisch verdächtig wird. Fasse ich jetzt mal ganz kurz zusammen, wie es dann wirklich funktioniert, das Thema im Laufe der Sendung. Aber wie gesagt, erst mal die beiden aktuellen Sachen. Die eine ist ja, der Herr Snowden war jetzt im Fernsehen zu sehen. Und das war ja nach einer ganzen Weile das erste Mal, dass man den Typen, der für die ganze Aufdeckungsüberwachungskandals überhaupt zuständig ist, dass man überhaupt wusste, dass der noch am Leben ist.
Und ich habe keine schlaflosen Nächte, weil ich getan habe, was ich für nötig hielt. Es war das Richtige und ich werde keine Angst haben.
Ich fand das tatsächlich ein bisschen gut, das zu sehen, weil man hat ihn, ich glaube, jetzt ein halbes Jahr lang nicht mehr gesehen. Der Herr Ströbele, unser Bundestagsabgeordneter, der war angeblich da und hat ihn getroffen, aber man wusste eigentlich nicht so genau, ob er am Leben ist. Oder, Andreas?
Na ja, es gab natürlich schon Kontakte, aber tatsächlich ist es der erste öffentliche Fernsehauftritt überhaupt seit den Veröffentlichungen und natürlich eine gute Nachricht. Ja, er lebt noch. Viel Überraschendes hat er nicht erzählt. Also auch aus dem Grund, dass er ja da dieses Arrangement mit Putin hat. Er darf den USA nicht schaden und dafür bekommt er Asyl. Also eine interessante Propagandaposition, die der Herr Putin da einnimmt. Er will natürlich der USA nicht schaden, auf gar keinen Fall. Er ist ein großer Freund der USA und so weiter und so fort. Also ein interessanter neuer kalter Krieg, der da ausgebrochen ist. Ja, ich gebe deinen Spion Asyl. Dafür schickst du mir irgendwie schwule Sportler nach Sochi.
In dem Interview hat Snowden ja immer wieder gesagt, er möchte jetzt zu diesem Thema, oder er kann es nicht immer sagen, weil er, das sind Journalisten, die seine Daten haben, überlässt, zu beurteilen, was an die Öffentlichkeit soll oder nicht. Aber der Verdacht ist halt genau, dass er einfach nur sich an dieses Abkommen hält, damit er das Asyl nicht verliert. Da kann man ja übrigens noch schön spekulieren. Er hat ja neulich auch so ein Chat-Interview gegeben, wo er quasi live Fragen beantwortet hat auf einer Internetseite. Bringt er sich jetzt also die freie Spekulation und Position für das nächste Asylland? Weil der Asylantrag in Russland läuft ja aus im Sommer.
Ja, na die Frage ist, wo möchte er denn hin? Also welches Land würde ihm denn Asyl geben? Ich glaube, er würde gerne nach Deutschland. Ich glaube, in Deutschland bekommen wir dafür keine passenden Mehrheiten, um das durchzuziehen. Ganz abgesehen davon, dass, wenn man Herrn Foschepot zum Beispiel glauben darf, da auch diverse Geheimverträge existieren, nach denen er sofort ausgeliefert werden müsste. Also Deutschland wäre technisch gar nicht dazu in der Lage, ihm Asyl zu gewähren, sondern wir müssten ihn ausliefern, entsprechend der Verträge, die wir haben.
Von denen wir aber nicht wissen, ob es sie gibt und wie sie lauten?
Zum Teil ja. Historiker erzählen uns, es gibt sie, aber wie das Geheimverträge so an sich haben, sind sie geheim. Was bleibt ihm sonst? Brasilien? Irgendwas in Südamerika?
Äquadorianische Botschaft?
Ja, also ich glaube, auf Dauer ist es ein bisschen ungemütlich. Es ist eine Art Luxusknast, da würde ich glaube ich auch nicht wohnen wollen.
Aber apropos Deutschland, er hat ja, also A kam es tatsächlich in einem Interview auch an einer Stelle vor, wo er gesagt hat, na ja, ich habe ja schon sozusagen mehrfach versucht, Asyl zu beantragen, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr in welchen Ländern, aber zum Beispiel auch, dann fiel der Name Deutschland, was ich auch interessant finde, ich habe mit einem amerikanischen Science Fiction Autoren gesprochen, der sich auch sozusagen für so eine anderen Sachen interessiert, Bruce Sterling und der hatte die, also ich fand seine Sicht interessant, weil er meinte, Entschuldigt mal Deutschland, ihr seid sozusagen von den Leuten, die jetzt nicht direkt an diesen Überwachungsdingen beteiligt sind, also diesen, wie heißen sie Five Eyes, diese großen Staaten, sondern da seid ihr eine der größten politischen Mächte. Warum macht ihr den jetzt? Warum geht ihr mit dem Typen nicht Asyl? Fand ich auch sehr, sehr, sehr spannend. Allerdings mit der Zusammenarbeit, naja, da hat er es nur dann auch die eine oder andere Sache dann doch nochmal gucken lassen.
Millionen und Millionen und Millionen von Datenverbindungen aus dem täglichen Leben der Deutschen, ob sie mit ihrem Handy telefonieren, SMS-Nachrichten senden, Webseiten besuchen, Dinge online einkaufen, all das landet bei der NSA.
Ja, also weil ja auch das sozusagen eine der Dinge ist, die immer wieder rumgehen, dass Leute denken, also der BND ist wahlweise zu doof, das ist das eine, was man immer hört, oder das machen die doch nicht. Aber also Snowden hat so relativ wortwörtlich zitiert gesagt, NSA und BND gehen zusammen ins Bett. Und das ist sozusagen eine der deutlicheren Sachen, die er da zu hören gegeben hat. Ist das keine große Überraschung für dich, Andreas?
Eine mittelgroße. Ich glaube, das erklärt auch, warum das mit dem Asyl schwierig werden wird, weil Deutschland ja durchaus auch profitiert. Es gibt den Zugang zu einem X-Key-Score-System, das ist etwas, was wir zumindest vermutet haben. Und auch dieses No-Spy-Abkommen, von dem immer viel geredet wurde, ist ja eigentlich weniger ein No-Spy-Abkommen, sondern der Versuch Deutschlands aus der zweiten Klasse Partner der USA zur ersten Klasse aufzurücken. Also der Versuch aus den Five Eyes, ein Six Eyes zu machen. So wir wollen auch gleichberechtigt mit den anderen Jungs mitspielen im internationalen Weltgeschehen. Und das ist auch, glaube ich, die wichtigste Botschaft, die darüber gekommen ist. Natürlich macht Deutschland damit. Natürlich weiß der BND davon. Natürlich benutzen die dieselben Systeme. Da findet ein Datenaustausch, ein Informationsaustausch, einen Austausch von Erkenntnissen statt, einen Austausch von Mitarbeitern, Schulungen und so weiter und so fort. Also Deutschland steckt einfach in der Überwachung genauso mit drin, wie die ganzen anderen Länder, von denen wir gehört haben.
Hurra! Sozusagen. Und dann gibt es ja die Idee, dass die immer wieder zu hören ist, dass man das, äh, das nicht das Deutschland ist. Vielleicht wäre das auch noch eine gute Idee, dass man das Internet sagen, in Teile, nationale Teile unterteilt. Und da ist das dann alles ganz sicher. Diese Idee, dass man quasi, also sowas wie eine deutsche E-Mail z.B. etabliert, hat ja das nur dann auch eine Absage erteilt. It's not gonna stop the NSA.
Es wird die NSA nicht daran hindern, ihre Arbeit fortzusetzen. Sagen wir es mal so. Die NSA geht dahin, wo die Daten sind. Wenn sie es schafft, Nachrichten aus den Telekommunikationsnetzen Chinas zu sammeln, wird es ihr vermutlich auch gelingen, an Facebook Nachrichten in Deutschland ranzukommen.
Tja, gut, hätten wir das auch geklärt. Also nicht nur, dass der BND mit der NSA wahrscheinlich zusammenarbeitet. Es hilft auch nichts, wenn wir unser eigenes Internet bauen. Keine große Überraschung, das haben wir, also ihr z.B. schon immer gesagt, mit ihr manche Club und so Leute, die angebliche Ahnung vom Internet haben.
Ja, die ganze Norden-Geschichte ist natürlich ein einziges Told you so. Also wir haben es schon immer gewusst, wir haben es schon immer geahnt. Also die meisten Leute waren ein bisschen schockiert, wie weit es dann wirklich geht. Also es gab auf dem Kongress eine Präsentation von real existierender Überwachungstechnik, die die NSA eingesetzt hat im Jahr 2008. Also alles schon ein bisschen älter. Aber wo also wirklich abstruse technische Lösungen, die z.B. darauf hinaus liefen, dass man mit einer großen Mikrowelle von außen gegen die Hauswand strahlt. Und dann in dem Tastaturkabel z.B. so eine Mini-Antenne drin ist, also noch nicht mehr Elektronik, sondern einfach bloß ein kleines Stückchen Metall. Und man von außen mit einer großen Mikrowelle, mit einer hohen Leistung dagegen strahlt und das reflektierte Signal sich anguckt, um Überwachung zu machen, solche Geschichten, dass auf dem Postwege Server abgefangen werden und dann in die Ethernet-Buchse, also da hinten, wo man sein Netzwerkkabel reinsteckt, diese Buchse, dass in diese Buchse ein WLAN-Router eingebaut wird, über den man dann Zugriff auf das Netzwerk hat und so weiter und so fort. Also eine ganze Liste von solchen Techniken, wo man auch hinterher dasteht und einfach nicht mehr weiß, wie man denn überhaupt gegen solche gezielte Angriffe vorgehen kann. Und das ist, glaube ich, eine wichtigste Erkenntnis, man kann viel tun, was die sogenannte Schleppnetzüberwachung angeht. Also das, worüber wir hier reden heute Abend hauptsächlich, dass man die großen Datenmengen nimmt, alles was anfällt, alles überwacht und versucht daraus Sachen zu extrahieren. Dagegen kann man, das ist die einzige gute Nachricht, die wir von Snowden mit Kryptographie etwas machen. Gegen gezielte Angriffe kann man sehr wenig machen.
Das war die eine Sache, die auch sozusagen den Weg ebnet, für das, worüber wir heute Abend sprechen wollen, nämlich die massive Massendaten überwachen und dann auch Analyse. Dazu kommen wir gleich, es gab noch eine zweite Neuigkeit, Nachricht diese Woche, die mit dem Chaos Computer Club zu tun hat, und zwar, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, wird die Bundesregierung verklagt, also so Strafanzeige gegen einzelne Politiker?
Ja, nicht nur das, es gibt auch eine Klage vom Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Diese Klage vom Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte halte ich tatsächlich für Erfolgversprechender als die Strafanzeige in die Bundesregierung, weil wer ermittelt denn gegen die Bundesregierung, das ist im Zweifel die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft, und wer ist denn Weisungsbefug gegenüber der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft, die Bundesregierung? Also das wird vermutlich nicht viel bringen, das ist eher ein politisches Signal, als dass da tatsächlich was passiert. Ich verspreche mir von der Klage vom Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte tatsächlich sehr sehr viel mehr, weil die unabhängig sind, die auf anderen Grundlagen, nämlich auf den vereinbarten Menschenrechten, die ja zum Beispiel auch im Vertrag von Lissabon festgelegt sind, werden auch im Anhang aber immerhin verbindlich entscheiden können und sich einfach mal objektiv angucken können, ob das, was zum Beispiel die Regierung Kamerander tut, ob das, was auch die Bundesregierung der BND tut, ob das überhaupt rechtmäßig ist, nämlich tatsächlich alle immer und überall komplett zu überwachen.
So, sehr gespannt, was dabei rauskommt. Das geht jetzt gerade erst los. Und jetzt kommen wir zum eigentlichen Thema der Sendung. Also jetzt, wo wir uns noch mal eine Viertelstunde Zeit genommen haben, um wirklich zu zeigen, dass mit Überwachung ist nicht nur so ein ausgedachtes Ding, wissen wir, diese ganzen Daten fallen also irgendwie an. Und dann hat halt die Frage, was macht man damit? Und da begrüße ich jetzt noch mal einzelne vorgestellt, die Gäste des heutigen Abends. Da haben wir zuallererst Joachim Scharloth, ein Linguistik-Professor. Wir werden später noch ausführlich darüber reden. Er rollt mit den Augen. Ist das was Schlimmes, ein Linguistik-Professor zu sein?
Nein, das ist das Beste, was man werden kann.
Okay, aber du kannst jetzt schon mal kurz erklären, was genau Linguistik mit Überwachung zu tun hat.
Abgesehen von den Metadaten, die natürlich anfallen, sind viele Daten, die wir jeden Tag zu produzieren, sprachlicher Art. Wir schreiben E-Mails, wir posten irgendwelche Sachen auf Facebook, wir twittern und all das kann man natürlich mit sprachlichen Methoden dann auch auswerten. Man kann dem Sinn, den wir mit diesen Worten verbinden, relativ nahe kommen, indem man sie mit der entsprechenden Software und den entsprechenden Algorithmen anschaut automatisch.
Okay, also das ist schon mal der wichtige Punkt, auf den wir nachher noch genauer aufgehen. Es muss nicht ein Mensch davor sitzen und sagen, okay, der hat was Böses gesagt, sondern man kann das, bis zu einem gewissen Grad zumindest auch berechnen.
Die Rolle des Menschen müssen wir dann noch mal diskutieren.
Die diskutieren wir noch mal, aber wir gucken erst mal, was dann auch mit dem Computer geht. Dann haben wir Simon Willnauer. Der ist, er würde jetzt bestimmt auch gleich mit den Augen rollen, heute der Praktiker. Simon, was machst du?
Also ich kümmere mich eigentlich mehr darum, die Software zu schreiben, die Linguisten und auch an Firmen oder die besagte NSA eventuell auch benutzen, um diese ganzen Daten zu verarbeiten und die Informationen daraus zu extrahieren.
Warte, du schreibst die Software für die NSA?
Naja, wir schreiben Open Source Software. Das heißt, sie könnten diese Software auch benutzen. Das ist Fluch und Segen. In dem Moment, wo sie frei ist, darf sie auch jeder benutzen. Da kann man an der Stelle nicht so viel dagegen tun.
Genau, und du bist heute hier, weil du eine derjenigen bist, die sich anbeschäftigen, wie man Daten massiv, also massive Anhäufung von Daten verarbeiten kann. Wir wollen das vor allen Dingen deshalb klären, weil die Idee oder die, wie soll man das sagen, sozusagen eine Hoffnung vielleicht auch immer ist, dass es so viele Daten sind, das könne man ja gar nicht alles bearbeiten. Dass es möglicherweise doch geht und wie viel Aufwand es ist, das klären wir heute noch mit Simon. Und dann haben wir noch Anna zugeschaltet. Hallo nochmal Anna. Die das versucht, was wir heute in der Sendung auch versuchen, nämlich zu erklären, was man mit diesen Daten alles machen kann. Anna ist Informatikerin und Bloggerin bei Netzpolitik, habt ihr möglicherweise schon mal gehört, ein Blog aus Berlin, und hat da so eine Artikel-Serie How to Analyze Everyone, also wie man wirklich jeden analysiert, sind erst zwei Teile erschienen, aber es ist genau dieses Thema. Anna, worüber hast du da schon geschrieben?
Ja, also bei dem ersten Artikel ging es einmal darum, dass es gerade diese Handy-Geschichte mit der NSA aktuell war, das heißt, dass die NSA ordnen konnte, was man denn mit Handyortungen, was man daraus extrapolieren kann, das heißt mit wem man unterwegs ist und mit welchen Menschen man sich wohin bewegt. Und der zweite Teil hat sich eben darum gedreht um sprachliche Aspekte, das heißt, wie ich rausfinden kann, ob ich irgendwas mag. Das heißt, wenn jemand meine Blogposts, meine Twitter-Posts, meine Facebook-Posts automatisch durchsucht, wie der feststellen kann, was ich so mag und welche Meinung ich auch zu bestimmten Themen habe. Das heißt, ob ich jetzt vielleicht ein radikaler Linker bin oder potenzieller Terrorattentäter oder irgendeine andere Kategorie von Menschen.
Wie viel über dieses Thema hast du gewusst, bevor du angefangen hast zu recherchieren?
Das kommt ganz auf die Themen drauf an.
Ja, also jetzt auch sagen, auf das Letzte, auf diese sprachliche Verarbeitung.
Das sprachliche Verarbeitungsthema war sogar im Studium mal, ist mir über den Weg gelaufen, nämlich in einem Seminar und das hat mich relativ fasziniert, weil ich eben mir gar nicht so bewusst dessen war, dass man Meinungen in großem Stil einfach automatisch analysieren kann und welche Formen das annehmen kann. Und für wen das eigentlich interessant ist. Das heißt, dass das für ganz verschiedene Interessengruppen interessant ist. Einmal für die Werbeindustrie, für die NSA eben auch und vielleicht auch für den zukünftigen Arbeitgeber.
Was hast du da entdeckt? Also wie funktioniert das? Also da hab ich immer noch so am Anfang gedacht, naja gut, wenn du jetzt einen Text in den Computerbogen ranwürfst, dann kann das halt irgendwie die Buchstaben zählen und vielleicht noch groß und klein Schreibungen und Rechtschreibungen unterscheiden. Aber wie findet das dann daraus aus, ob da eine Meinung dahinter steckt oder nicht?
Das erste, was wir brauchen, man muss dem Computer sozusagen beibringen, was eine Meinung überhaupt ist. Das heißt, er ist ja erstmal doof und zieht wirklich nur Buchstaben. Und da muss man ihm einmal erstmal beibringen, was sind Wörter, was ist die Grammatik dahinter, was ist der Sinn hinter den einzelnen Wörtern und was ist jetzt wirklich diese Meinung. Und da gibt es eben verschiedene Modelle, wie jetzt das zum Beispiel eine Meinung dadurch gebildet wird, dass ich einmal das Meinungsobjekt habe, dass worüber ich mir die Meinung bilde, dann habe ich von diesem Objekt bestimmte Unterobjekte. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel über Politik generell rede, dann habe ich vielleicht eine andere Meinung zur CDU, als ich zu Angela Merkel habe. Und dann hat jedes Wort ja auch eine Bedeutung. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt sage, das ist grottenschlecht, dann weiß ich, das ist eine negative Meinung, aber es ist auch noch eine sehr negative Meinung, die jetzt schlechter ist als nur das Wort schlecht. Und das muss man dem Computer eben auch beibringen. Und wie man das macht, kann man eben auf ganz viele verschiedene Arten und Weisen angehen. Und man muss eben auch berücksichtigen, dass ich jetzt aus einem kurzen Textschnippel, wie jetzt eine Twitter-Meldung, ganz andere Informationen ziehen kann, wie aus einer ausführlichen Filmrezension zum Beispiel. Und dass ich da auch ganz andere Techniken und ganz andere Erkenntnisse drauf anwenden muss.
Hat dich die Ergebnisse einer Recherche haben, die dich dann erschreckt? Also was man da alles rausziehen kann aus diesen Sachen?
Auf der einen Seite erschreckt, auf der anderen Seite auch fasziniert. Das heißt auch die Schwierigkeiten, die es dabei gibt und vor allem die Bandbreite an Lösungen, die es dabei gibt, hat mich fasziniert. Und zum Beispiel auch Aspekte, die mir vorher gar nicht bewusst waren. Nämlich, dass man nicht einfach so ein generelles Modell schaffen kann, sondern dass man auch für jede Sprache zum Beispiel ein eigenes Modell schaffen muss. Dass man für jeden Kulturkreis eigene Modelle schaffen muss. Dass es zum Beispiel einen Unterschied macht, ob ich jetzt aus Europa komme oder aus Asien, wenn es zum Beispiel um Ironie und um Färbung von gewissen Sprachkonstrukten geht. Und dass man vielleicht dann einfach nicht pauschal sagen kann, ich analysiere jetzt das Internet.
Also sagen, die Analyse ist dann immer auf ganz bestimmte Dinge eingeschränkt. Also in deinem Beispiel sind zum Beispiel Filmkritiken. Jetzt ist ja die Texte, die du da geschrieben hast, das sind alles aus öffentlich verfügbaren Informationen oder es bezog sich auf öffentliche verfügbare Informationen. Jetzt kann man sagen, wenn ich nichts mehr öffentlich ins Netz schreibe, dann kann mich auch niemand mehr analysieren. Aber das ist ja möglicherweise nicht das, was wir wollen, weil das Netz ja dann doch auch irgendwie cool ist und Spaß macht. Gibt es da irgendwie Techniken dagegen? Hast du da welche entdeckt zumindest?
Du meinst Techniken dagegen, dass man sich analysieren lassen kann?
Dass man sich analysieren lassen kann, genau. Also kann ich eine meinungsstarke Filmkritik schreiben, ohne dass jemand meine Meinung, warte, also ohne dass ein Computer meine Meinung rausfinden kann?
Das einzige, was man glaube ich wirklich verhindern kann, ist, dass der Computer rausfindet, dass es meine Meinung ist. Das heißt, es ist ja vielleicht gar nicht so tragisch, dass jetzt die Filmfirma rausfindet, wie gerade die breite Masse an Menschen ihren Film findet. Aber vielleicht will ich ja eben nicht, dass der Verfassungsschuss rausfindet, dass ich jetzt eher dem linken Spektrum angehöre. Das ist ja schon ein Unterschied von dem, was ich vielleicht verhindern will und was in Ordnung wäre. Das heißt, ich kann zum Beispiel erstmal versuchen, nicht für jeden Dienst das gleiche Pseudonym oder sogar meinen Klarnamen zu verwenden. Wenn ich jetzt alles über mein eigenes Google Konto mache und über meine Google Plus Seite meine Meinung veröffentlich, ist natürlich klar, dass jeder weiß, was ich für eine Meinung habe. Aber wenn ich jetzt überall erstmal ein anderes Pseudonym und ein verschiedenes Konto und auch verschiedene Dienste benutze, ist es erstmal nicht so einfach. Und wenn ich dann auch noch durch Techniken wie Tor und so weiter verhindere, dass ich alles von der gleichen IP-Adresse mache, dann wird es eben noch mal schwieriger, die ganzen Einzelmeinungen, die ich verbreite, auf mich zurückzuführen.
Man muss also viele sein im Internet, das macht uns vielleicht hier zufrieden. Was werden denn in einer Artikelserie die nächsten Sachen sein, die du bearbeitest, um herauszufinden, wie wir alle analysiert werden können?
Das nächste, was ich geplant habe, ist ein Artikel über Techniken, wie man vorhersagen kann, wo man sich als nächstes aufhalten wird. Das heißt, da gibt es auch ganz, sag ich mal, gruselige Geschichten, die eben aus Daten setzen, wo ich mich vorher aufgehalten habe, die zum Beispiel über mein Handy ermittelt wurden, bestimmen können, wo ich mich wahrscheinlich dann in der nächsten Stunde aufhalten werde oder wo ich mich wahrscheinlich hinbewegen werde.
Okay, und das funktioniert schon, das wird schon gemacht, oder ist es noch eine Idee, die in der Entwicklung ist?
Das wird schon gemacht und es gab vor ein paar Jahren, gab es da einen riesigen Datensatz zu, das hat nämlich Nokia gemacht, die haben Freiwillige in der Schweiz gefunden, relativ viele, die über einen ziemlich langen Zeitraum quasi ein Handy mit GPS-Sender witzig getragen haben und eben fleißig ihre Standortinformationen weitergegeben haben. Und seit es diesen riesigen Datensatz mit jeweils den einzelnen Personen gab, ist da ziemlich viel Forschung passiert und ziemlich viele Leute haben sich da eben raufgestürzt und versucht, da Informationen rauszugewinnen und das Feld ist so ein bisschen aufgeblüht.
Na, das kann ja noch alter werden. Jetzt ist ja, und das ist die andere Perspektive auf das, was du machst. Du hast das ja für einen Blog geschrieben, für netzpolitik.org, mit dem Ziel, das so zu erklären, dass du, hab ich zumindest verstanden, dass es möglichst viele verstehen. Weißt du, ob dir das gelungen ist oder was hast du für Reaktionen auf deinen Artikel bekommen?
Also ich hab zum Beispiel jetzt, sag ich mal, von meiner Mutter die Reaktion bekommen, dass sie weinte, ach, das ist ja doch gar nicht so einfach und ja, da müsste man ja eigentlich mal was machen. Das heißt, dieses klassische, ja, da hab ich ja nichts zu verbergen und ich bin ja langweilig, zieht dann eben nicht mehr ganz, weil man eben dann auch sieht, dass vielleicht weiß man ja gar nicht, was man zu verbergen hat. Vielleicht denken ja die anderen oder vielleicht findet ja der Computer irgendwas raus, was nicht mal unbedingt stimmen muss und was dann doch plötzlich irgendwie verdächtlich ist. Wir hatten ja, also der Fall von Andre Holm ist ja relativ bekannt. Das heißt, er war Soziologe und hat über Gentrifizierung geschrieben und plötzlich stand eine Truppe bei ihm vor der Tür und meinte, er wäre in der militanten Szene unterwegs, weil er eben ungefähr die gleiche Wortwahl benutzt. Und er wusste ja überhaupt nicht, dass er angeblich irgendwas zu verbergen hat. Und das kann ja prinzipiell jedem passieren, weil so eine Software ja auch Fehler machen kann.
Und diesen Effekt hast du mit den Artikeln auch erreicht?
Ja, doch auf jeden Fall, weil eben diese Überwachung nicht mehr so abstrakt wird und man sich denkt, ja da kommen Daten in eine Maschine rein und am Ende kommt irgendwas raus. Sondern wenn man mal sich selber auch so ein bisschen reflektiert und sich überlegt, was an meiner Sprache und was an dem, was ich im letzten Taster könnte, verdächtig sein, auch wenn es für mich selber relativ abwegig erscheint, merken doch viele, dass sie vielleicht nicht vorsichtig sein müssen, aber dass es nicht ausgeschlossen ist, dass sie plötzlich in so ein Raster fallen.
Glaubst du, dass sich diese Erkenntnis, dass man die langfristig irgendwie durchsetzen kann? Oder wird es immer nur einigen wenigen vorbehalten sein, sich auf diese Art und Weise verrückt zu machen?
Auf der einen Seite muss ich sagen, ich hoffe, dass sich Leute nicht verrückt machen, sondern primel sich dessen bewusst werden und sich dann eben mit den Möglichkeiten, die sie haben, schützen, um sich eben nicht selbst zu zensieren. Weil im Prinzip der Effekt, den ich nicht erreichen will, ist, dass Leute plötzlich online nichts mehr von sich preisgeben und überhaupt nicht mehr online partizipieren, sondern dass Leute sich einfach dessen bewusst werden und sich so gut schützen, wie sie eben können und nicht mehr alles und die im Klarnamen veröffentlichen zumindest.
Okay, also auch das ist eine spannende Beobachtung. Man kann sich auch mit dem Thema, was ist eigentlich durch Überwachung alles möglich beschäftigen, ohne gleich zu sagen, wir dürfen nichts mehr im Internet machen und müssen selbst unsere klarsten öffentlichsten Aussagen verschlüssen. Anna, vielen Dank in diesen Einblick in das Blog Netzpolitik Org und die Art und Weise, wie man versuchen kann, einer breiteren Öffentlichkeit zu beschreiben, was man mit Überwachungsdaten eigentlich alles anstellen kann. Damit ist der erste Schritt heute in der Sendung getan, denn genau das wollen wir heute hier erreichen. Wir sprechen jetzt gleich darüber, was man eigentlich dafür an Leistungsfähigkeit braucht, also an Hardwaren, Programmierkram, wie viel Aufwand das ist, ob man dazu ein riesiger Geheimdienst sein muss, um, sagen wir mal, keine Ahnung, alle unsere Twitterdaten zu verarbeiten und ob es möglicherweise auch mit unserem kleinen Hauscomputer geht. Machen wir gleich. Vorher gibt es noch eine ganz kurze Musik und die Nachrichten. Dann hören wir uns wieder hier im Chaosradio.
Die Skiwelt nass hält.
Und das nicht allein.
Ihr plus eine Begleitung für eine ganze Woche. Inklusive Flug mit German Wings, Hotel und Skipässe.
Ab Montag immer bei den Radio-Fritzen. Am Morgen und am Nachmittag.
Einfach gut fritzen.
Mehr dazu fritz.de slash piste. Mal eben vor zum Wintersport. Ab Montag, auf Fritz.
Fritz Nachrichten.
Formel 1-Rekord-Weltmeister Michael Schumacher wird aus dem künstlichen Koma geholt. Schumachers Managerin hat heute bestätigt, dass die Narkosemittel jetzt nach und nach reduziert werden. Der Aufwachprozess kann aber sehr lange dauern. Schumacher war kurz vor dem Jahreswechsel beim Skifahren verunglückt. Wegen seiner schweren Hirnverletzungen hatten die Ärzte ihnen ein künstliches Koma versetzt. Bundeswirtschaftsminister Gabriel will die Energiewende nicht alleine gestalten. Der SPD-Politiker hat gesagt, dass er mit den Bundesländern zusammenarbeiten will. Bei der Energiewende gibt es Streit darüber, wie der Umstieg von Atom- und Kohlestrom am besten funktionieren könnte. Gabriel will die Förderung von Windkraftanlagen an Land kürzen und das kritisieren mehrere Bundesländer. Berlin hat das Studium für angehende Lehrer umgemodelt. In Zukunft wird es statt vier nur noch drei Studiengänge geben. Einen für Grundschulen, einen für Sekundarschulen und Gymnasien sowie einen für berufliche Schulen. Wer Sonderschullehrer werden will, muss zusätzlich das Fach Sonderpädagogik belegen. Ein Praxissemester wird eingeführt und das Referendariat wird für alle Lehrämter anderthalb Jahre dauern.
Sport!
Die Basketballer von Alba Berlin haben das Eurocup-Spiel in der Ukraine gewonnen. Bei Uschne gab es einen 68 zu 65 Sieg nach Verlängerung. Das Spiel musste um einen Tag verschoben werden, weil die Berliner bei ihrer Anreise im Schneesturm stecken geblieben waren. Die aktuellen Temperaturen. In Berlin immer noch überall minus 4 Grad, nur Spandau minus 3 Grad. Cottbus und Angermünde minus 5, Potsdam und Faltensee minus 4 Grad. Nachts können noch einzelne Flocken fallen, es kann aber auch kurzzeitig Sternen klar werden, bei Tiefstwerten um die minus 6 Grad. Morgen dann viel Wolken, aber kaum noch Schnee und Tauwetter bei bis zu plus 5 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin 100. Stadtring in beiden Richtungen stockt es immer mal wieder. Mitte die Wilhelmstraße ist zwischen Leipziger Straße und Beerenstraße in beiden Richtungen gesperrt, da ist ein Kran im Einsatz. Brandenburg A12, Frankfurt Oder Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Grenzübergang Frankfurt Oder und Frankfurt Oder Süd hat es auf der linken Spur gekracht. 113 Zubringer Schönefeld statt einwärts. Zwischen Schönefelder Kreuz und Dreieckwald das Dorf, da stehen Tiere am Fahrbahnrand. Und noch zur S-Bahnlinie S2. Bis Betriebsschluss wird der Abschnitt zwischen Blankenfelde und Lichtenrade unterbrochen. Stattdessen fahrende Busse. Zwischen Lichtenrade und Marienfelde besteht ein Pendelverkehr im 20-Minuten-Takt. Ochmein, seid gute Fahrt!
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Ritz und es geht um die massenhafte Überwachung von uns und was man dann überhaupt damit macht. Weil das Problem ist immer, ja natürlich, die überwachen uns halt alle, aber was machen sie dann damit? Das wollen wir heute mal erklären. Also zumindest das, was technisch möglich ist. Damit begrüße ich wiederum die vier Gäste, die heute hier sind. Anna Biselli, Andreas, Simon und Joachim. Hallo und guten Abend noch mal zusammen. So, wir haben gerade mit Anna geklärt, die für Netzpolitik Texte schreibt, wo sie auch das versucht, was wir versuchen, nämlich in der Öffentlichkeit zu erklären, wie das mit diesem Überwachungsding so funktioniert. Und haben also schon Reaktionen darauf gehört und grob, was da so möglich ist, zum Beispiel, indem man Sprache überwacht. Das werden wir noch ein bisschen weiter ausführen. Wir wollen vor allen Dingen jetzt mal drüber sprechen. Diese massenhaften Datenverarbeitung, bevor wir feststellen, was da alles geht, die muss ja auch jemand machen. Also da muss ja irgendwo ein Computer stehen und da muss irgendjemand irgendwas programmiert haben, was dann irgendwie dieses Ding analysiert. Und wenn man immer diese Horrormeldung hört, dass irgendwie Millionen und Milliardenfach unsere Daten abgehört werden, dann denkt man sich so, hm, naja, das müsste aber schon so irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, ein statengroßes Rechenzentrum sein, wo aber Trilliarden von Prozessoren dran werkeln. Oder es ist vielleicht doch anders. Und deswegen ist Simon Willnauer hier, der nämlich genau so was, naja, vielleicht programmiert. Genau, noch mal langsam. Was machst du eigentlich?
Also eigentlich beschäftige ich mich damit, Suchmaschinen zu bauen. Das ist, was ich seit einigen Jahren mache. Und naja, der Begriff Suchmaschine, den kennt eigentlich jeder. Ich meine, wer benutzt Google nicht mehrmals täglich oder irgendeine andere der großen bekannten Suchmaschinen? Eigentlich jeder, der im Internet unterwegs ist.
Warum baut man dann noch neue, wenn es die doch eh schon gibt?
Na ja, ich meine, die Google-Suchmaschine, die kann mir zwar das ganze Internet durchsuchen, aber wenn ich zum Beispiel meine eigenen Daten durchsuchen will als Firma oder auch als Privatperson, dann möchte ich die vielleicht nicht direkt Google zur Verfügung stellen, sodass Google sie durchsuchen kann, aber ich möchte meinen eigenen Service, meinen eigenen Dienst zur Verfügung stellen, um diese Daten zu durchsuchen. Eine der bekanntesten Suchmaschinen, die jetzt nicht Google ist, würde ich sagen, ist die Wikipedia-Suche, die hat auch jeder schon mal benutzt.
Und sowas baust du also? Genau. Und wie kommt es jetzt dazu, dass es in diese Analyse massenhafter Datenberge reinpasst? Also bist du da auch so jemand, wo man sagt, okay, hier, mach doch mal in sofort alle Twitter-Nachrichten und sag mir, wie oft da drin das Wort grün vorkommt, oder?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, was ich darauf antworte, nein, also es geht eigentlich eher darum, dass die die Technologie, die man dazu benutzt, um einerseits Daten zu analysieren und andererseits Daten zu durchsuchen, sehr, sehr ähnlich ist und was immer mehr aufkommt, ist Suchtmaschinen oder die Technologie, die man als Suchtmaschinen bezeichnet, auch zur Datenanalyse benutzt, weil sie einerseits mit sehr, sehr großen Datenmengen gut umgehen kann. Es gibt den technischen Begriff, die Datenstrukturen, die dafür gebaut sind, kann man sehr gut benutzen, um Informationen zu extrahieren, Daten zu aggregieren, zu sehen, welche Teile der Informationen, welche Teile der Dokumente, der Texte relevant sind oder nicht. Und da stellen sich so Synergien her, die man da auch ausnutzen kann in der Stelle.
Joachim, hebt die Hand. Möchtest du etwas sagen?
Ich habe einfach eine interessante Zwischenfrage, weil du gesagt hast, Suchen und Datenanalyse nähert sich immer mehr an. Inwiefern ist es denn schon das Gleiche geworden? Und bzw. inwiefern mache ich eigentlich vorher das Gleiche? Also wenn ich suche, analysiere ich ja im Grunde schon. Und was heißt das eigentlich für die automatische Durchforstung von großen Datenmengen durch Geheimdienste? Ist das dann nur eine Suche oder ist das nicht auch schon eine Analyse?
Es ist auf jeden Fall beides. Also an der Stelle werden für einen dieselbe Sache die gleichen Werkzeuge benutzt. Man kann sich das wirklich als Werkzeuge vorstellen. Die Werkzeuge allein machen es natürlich nicht. Wenn ich einen Bagger fahren kann, brauche ich immer noch einen Bagger. Aber wenn ich einen Bagger habe, heißt das noch nicht, dass ich Bagger fahren kann. Da gehören immer beide Seiten dazu. Einerseits die Werkzeuge, um die Analyse wirklich auszuführen und das Wissen, wie man diese Werkzeuge benutzt. Und dann fehlen nur noch die Daten.
Dann kann es losgehen.
Nochmal sagen, man wirft diese Daten da rein. In meinem einfachen Vorstellungsgeist ist es ja so, eine Suchmaschine ist letztendlich nichts anderes als eine Textsuche. Also wenn ich in einem Textdokument, Steuerung F drücke, ein Wort eingebe, dann sucht man jetzt einfach die Erscheinungsstelle in diesem Text heraus. Aber wenn ich jetzt Daten analysieren will, gehört da anscheinend ein bisschen mehr dazu.
Das Spannende ist ja, wenn man dann versucht, Sachen zu verknüpfen. Also wenn man mal bei den Twitter-Nachrichten bleiben. Wir bauen ein System, wo alle Twitter-Nachrichten reinfallen. Dann zu sagen, gib mir mal alle, in denen das Wort grün vorkommt, ist ja eine einfache Suche. Aber irgendwie gib mir mal alles, wo irgendwie Merkel und Doof vorkommt. Das ist ja eine Verknüpfung dieser beiden Suchen. Und das ist ja schon ein Stückchen eine Analyse. Nämlich irgendwie ein Vorkommen von diesen beiden Worten im selben Tweet. Und da ist glaube ich die... Also da kommen dann wieder die Analysten ins Spiel. Also Kolokation von Suchworten ist sozusagen der Terminus von der Analyse-Seite her. Und such mal die Twitter-Nachrichten, wo diese beiden Worte zusammen vorkommen. Das ist der technische Teil der Suche. Also da an der Stelle verknüpft sich das.
Aber es geht sozusagen schlicht und einfach um Textanalyse. Oder gibt es da auch mehr?
Es gibt auf jeden Fall mehr. Geografische Analyse zum Beispiel. Wenn man jetzt zu den verknüpften Worten oder Texten auch noch eine geografische Information dazusetzt, sagt, wo kommt diese Information her? Von wo ist dieser Tweet gesendet worden? Aus welchem geografischen Teil der Erde? Zu welchem Zeitpunkt? Und wie viele Tweets kamen in einem bestimmten Zeitintervall aus einer bestimmten geografischen Location?
Kann man das dann auch mit anderen Daten verknüpfen? Man weiß ja von Twitterern manchmal keine Ahnung, wo ihre Webseite ist, was für ein Geschlecht sie haben oder welchen Namen sie haben oder so was?
Ja, das ist dann am Ende wirklich eine Aggregation, die ich mir beliebig zu sein stellen kann. Ich kann aggregieren über wo kommen die Tweets her, zu welchem Zeitpunkt, welche Sprache hat diese Person benutzt auf ihrem Telefon, sind positive oder negative Worte vorgekommen in den Tweets, welche davon sind da vorgekommen? Und das ist auch wirklich, woraus es hinausläuft. Es ist nicht so, dass die Maschine mir hinterher einen Satz gibt und sagt, ich habe hier fünf Personen gefunden, die haben politische Absichten in einer bestimmten Ausprägung. Sondern es geht eher darum, zu sagen, im Moment kommen Informationen aus bestimmten Teilen der Erde, die eine gewisse Aussage, eine positive oder eine negative Aussage über ein abstraktes Thema haben.
Da können wir uns jetzt zwei Fragen anstellen. Also die eine ist sozusagen, wie viele von diesen Daten kannst du, also nur falls jetzt der Eindruck entsteht, es ist nicht so, dass du jetzt eine Twitter-Analyse-Maschine baust, sondern das nehmen wir jetzt gerade nur als Beispiel.
Richtig.
Genau. Und jetzt fließt sich die Frage an, wie viele dieser Daten kannst du denn gleichzeitig verarbeiten und dann wie schnell geht das? Also weil ich denke immer noch, es ist die eine Sache, wenn ich so einen großen Textblock irgendwo reinwerfe und dann einfach drei Wochen warte, bis er analysiert ist. Und die andere ist genau, wie viel geht überhaupt? Also wie viel kann man da reinwerfen in die Maschinen, die du baust?
Also das Spektrum ist da natürlich relativ groß. Schwer abhängig davon, wie viel Hardware, also wie viel Computer ich am Ende zur Verfügung habe, um das Ganze aufzubauen. Aber am Ende des Tages ist es wirklich eine Frage des Geldes. Wenn ich genug monetäre Mittel zur Verfügung habe, kann ich wirklich so viele Computer kaufen, dass das auch in einem ganz, ganz großen Stil, also hunderten von tausenden Dokumenten pro Sekunde in ein, zwei Sekunden ausgewertet ist. Also das ist durchaus möglich. Da kann man schon fast von Echtzeit sprechen.
Wenn du jetzt monetäre Mittel sagst, von welchen Größenordnungen reden wir da? Also lass uns einfach das Beispiel nehmen, wenn jemand kommt zu dir und sagt, Simon, sagt er, pass mal auf, ganz Twitter, bau das mal bitte. Was würdest du denn für eine Hausnummer veranschlagen?
Das ist sehr schwer zu sagen.
Natürlich. Aber reden wir von Faltastiliaden, Trilliaden, Millionen?
Also ich würde, die gesamte Datenmenge von Twitter, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau, wie viel das ist.
Ich hab grad mal nachgekostet, 500 Millionen Tweets am Tag.
500 Millionen Tweets am Tag. Ich meine, da braucht man schon eine ganz schöne Infrastruktur, um das wegzuschreiben. Allein schon, um es zu speichern. Muss ich mir überlegen, was ist der Speicherblatt? Das sind ja nicht nur die 140 Characters. Nicht nur die 140 Zeichen, die da gespeichert werden, sondern es wird auch noch gespeichert, wann, wo, wo kommt das her, auf welchem Gerät kam das, zu welcher Uhrzeit etc. etc. Da kommt natürlich schon ein Haufen da zusammen. Und auf der einen Seite muss ich mir eben die Hardware anschaffen, dass ich das speichern kann. Festplatten, die groß genug sind. Auf der anderen Seite die Rechenleistung, um was zu verarbeiten. Und die Leute, die sich darum kümmern, dass diese Maschinen auch funktionieren.
Aber so, welches Gerät ist das? Zehn Rechner, hundert Rechner, tausend Rechner?
Ich würde eher sagen, zehntausende Rechner, die zusammen spielen an der Stelle. Bei dem Datenaufkommen.
Jetzt denkt aber der normale Radiohörer, warte mal, zehntausend Rechner, ich schau mir jetzt diesen Desktop vor, der bei mir unter dem Schreibtisch steht, davon zehntausend. Das ist ja mehrere Fußballfelder groß. Aber Rechner sind ja sozusagen in der Fachsprache eher kleinere Geräte, die man in so Regale reinschiebt. Also, kannst du mal so... Also kannst du... Okay, wir weisen jetzt an dieser Stelle...
Können Sie mal durchrechnen, so ein neunzehntausend Rechner.
Warte mal, ich möchte... Wir machen jetzt Spekulation. Also was wir sagen, das möchte nicht bitte jemand hinterher hingehen und sagen, wir haben aber gesagt, dafür braucht man nur 19.234 Rechner, sondern wir spekulieren jetzt einfach. Und zwar nur um ein Gefühl für die Größenordnung zu bekommen. Darum geht es. So, dass also danach, wie wir das jetzt gesagt haben, also du wirst nicht festgenagelt, aber bitte eine Größenordnung, wie so eine Operation aussehen könnte.
Also ich sag mal mal eine komplette Größenordnung von einem Petabyte in kleinen Dokumenten kann ich durchaus auf einer Rechenfarm von circa 5 bis 600, 700 Rechnern kann ich schon ordentlich was anstellen. Und 500, 600, 700 Rechner, das hört sich jetzt viel an. Das sind jetzt nicht 500, 600, 700 Computer, die ich nebenhin stelle und die muss ich mir alle kaufen. Die kann sich jeder Normalsterbliche mit einer Kreditkarte innerhalb von 15 Minuten starten.
Das ist sozusagen dieses Cloud, von dem wir mal reden. Richtig. Wie teuer ist da einer?
Das kommt darauf an, wie groß die sind. Da kann man aber bei einer kleineren Maschine von so was 30 bis 40 Euro pro Monat, wenn der einen Monat durchläuft, rechnen.
Also das heißt aber, wenn man sich das alles, was du jetzt gesagt hast, zu dem dich erst hinreißen lassen, wenn man das zusammennimmt, ist die Analyse riesiger Datenmengen, zwar ein ordentliches Sümmchen, aber durchaus eines, das man aufbringen kann. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wenn man das jetzt alle miteinander multiplizieren, kommen wir auf irgendwie 20.000 Euro im Monat für eine Maschine, die uns ganz fitter in 24 Stunden auswertet.
Das hört sich dann schon wieder nicht mehr so viel an.
Das ist durchaus bezahlbar für jemanden, der ein Interesse daran hat. Also es sind kein Spiel, das nur die ganz, ganz Großen spielen können, sondern das ist auch etwas, was, sagen wir mal, jede mittelständische Politikberatung für einen machen kann.
Hm, wie war dann nochmal das Budget von der NSA? Weiß man nicht genau, ob das geheim ist, richtig? Aber möglicherweise mehrere Millionen. Jetzt hast du ja auch gesagt, die Hardware ist das eine, was man braucht, das andere ist, man muss ja Leute, die diese ganze Analyse-Software erst mal schreiben. Die sind wahrscheinlich auch erst mal teuer, weil das sind ja Superspezial-Experten. Aber muss man so eine Software dann sozusagen betreuen, im Sinne von, dass man da ständig die Superspezial-Experten ratet, oder kann man daraus auch eine Software machen, die von, ich sage mal, ausgebildeten Normalsterblichen bedient werden kann?
Also ich denke, das Weiterentwickeln dieser Software-Systeme und diese Algorithmen ist auf jeden Fall im Moment den Spezialisten überlassen. Das Betreuen eines laufenden Systems, dafür gibt es natürlich auch wirklich für diese Betreuung Spezialisten, wobei die eher nicht in die Kategorie Sprachanalyse oder Analyse-Experten, von denen gibt es auf jeden Fall mehr auf unserem Planeten als hochspezialisierte Sprachanalyse-Experten, wie einer, der neben mir sitzt hier. An der Stelle muss ich aber auch ganz klar sagen, es gehört wesentlich mehr dazu, als nur diese Rechner zu starten. Man kann nicht davon ausgehen, dass sich jetzt wirklich jeder ohne ein gewisses Vorwissen hinstellen kann und sagt, ich starte 10.000 Rechner oder 1.000 Rechner, wie viele auch immer. Und dann sagt, jetzt mache ich eine Analyse und dann weiß ich alles von allen Leuten und kann sagen, welche politische Ausrichtung diese Person hat. So funktioniert es zum Glück noch nicht.
Okay, aber die Leute, das System ist fertig und muss noch bedient werden, was für ein... Also wenn man es mal so grob sagen in einem Ausbildungslevel festlegen wollen würde, ist es dann so, okay, jeder der Informatik bis zu Ende studiert hat, könnte das? Oder muss man dann nochmal eine Spezialausbildung? Das ist halt die Frage. Also klar, es kann halt nicht jeder, nicht jeder kann sich dann diese Maschine setzen, aha, allmächtiger Überwachungsgott. Oder man braucht schon, man muss schon Informatiker sein quasi, aber wie kompliziert ist es, auf diesen Wissenstand zu kommen?
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass ein Studium davon nötig ist an der Stelle. Aber fundiertes Wissen über Informatik ist auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr hilfreich an der Stelle. Was sehr, sehr wichtig ist, dass man sich dafür interessiert. Dann kann man mit den heutigen Mitteln und mit der Anzahl der Informationen, die da sind, und der nötigen Zeit auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr, sehr viel interessante Informationen rausholen aus bestehenden Daten. Ich denke, dass die Hauptzahl oder die hauptsächliche Benutzer dieser Systeme oder die Entwickler dieser Systeme auf jeden Fall Informatik oder was Ähnliches studiert haben, Mathematik ist auch sehr hilfreich. Linguistik, gewisses Wissen über die Sprache, die man analysiert, ist auf jeden Fall, würde ich sagen, ganz vorausgesetzt, um da an der Stelle was zu weisen.
Aber es geht ja hier sozusagen um eine Machbarkeitsstudie. Wenn ich jemand wäre, der solche Leute anstellen möchte, dann habe ich jetzt nicht die Auswahl aus zehn Spezialexperten aus der Welt, sondern ich kann einfach sagen, gezielt Leute suchen, die ein informatisches Grundverständnis haben, die Bock auf so eine Arbeit haben, mir gebe ich gutes Geld in die Hand, sage hier, ich will euch nochmal ein System aus, und dann ist alles kein Problem.
Auf jeden Fall. Man muss ja auch sehen, dass man nicht eine Person braucht, die das alles auf einmal kann. Man kann ja auch das aufteilen auf mehrere Köpfe, zum Beispiel die Leute, die hier hinter dem Studio sitzen. Ich glaube, so unter uns würden wir so ein System auch zusammengenagelt bekommen.
Ich koch den Kaffee.
Ich dachte, du machst dann Marketing, PR.
Ja natürlich, kauft unser Überwachungssystem. Unser Überwachungssystem ist super und es ist überwachend.
Ich hab noch ein paar mehr Zahlen gegoogelt. Also am Tag werden in Deutschland 180 Millionen SMS verschickt. Das kann man jetzt auch mal hochrechnen aufs Jahr, da sind das also ein paar Milliarden. Dann müsste man also, wenn man die komplette SMS der Bundesrepublik auswerten wollte, bräuchte man dann wahrscheinlich nochmal das 20-fache von dem, was wir gerade ausgerechnet haben. Also mit einer flotten Million, das ist in einem Budget eines durchschnittlichen Landesamtes durchaus noch drin. Da könnte man sich auch ein System hinstellen, um alle SMS in Deutschland auszuwerten.
Glaubt ihr, also jetzt alle einzelnen Leute, die gerade hier im Studio oder am Studio zugeschaltet sind, glaubt ihr, dass es irgendetwas gibt, was mit Textanalyse zu tun hat, was nicht machbar ist für einen großen Geheimdienst, der einen Milliardenbudget hat? Also gibt es da überhaupt noch Grenzen?
Ja.
Welche?
Welche Grenzen gibt es da noch?
Das fängt bei ganz banalen Dingen an, so wie dass ein Text eine feste Bedeutung hat. Also sozusagen in dem Diskurs, in dem wir jetzt stecken, ist es so, es gibt einen Text, der ist irgendwie da, den können wir abschneucheln und dann können wir den lesen. Dabei ist das ja gar nicht so, sondern Texte kriegen eine Bedeutung dadurch, dass sich ein Leser mit ihnen auseinandersetzt. Das heißt, jeder Leser macht einen anderen Sinn aus dem Text. Und das ist aber nicht etwas, was sozusagen dem Text fremd wäre, oder was an einem anderen herangetragen wird, sondern das ist dem Text selbst und den Strukturen des Textes und den Strukturen der Sprache schon inhärent. Also das ist schon in der Sprache drin, dass sie nicht eindeutig ist. Das ist schon mal so ein Punkt, das kann man halt nicht so ohne weiteres abbilden.
Lass mich das nochmal versuchen zu verstehen. Du sagst, man kann einem System zwar beibringen, eine Bedeutung aus dem Text rauszuziehen, aber man weiß nicht, ob es die richtige ist und man weiß auch nicht, ob es die ist, die der Typ gemeint hat, der es geschrieben hat oder dass es die ist, die der Typ gemeint hat, der es gelesen hat. Also man kann sozusagen eine Bedeutung rausziehen, okay.
Also man schreibt dem Text eine Bedeutung zu, und zwar mit der Macht, die dieses System eben hat und mit dem Regime, was hinter diesem System steckt, also mit dem Kontrollregime und dem Strafregime möglich, aber ob das mit dem irgendwas zu tun hat, was der Sinn dieses Textes für die Leserinnen und Produzentinnen gegebenenfalls gewesen ist, das...
Das bringen wir dann gleich zu einem anderen spannenden Punkt, nämlich was die Leute mit dem Ergebnis machen, dass auch so eine Maschine rausfällt. Das würde ich gerne noch mal schieben, bis wir quasi alle Systeme erklärt haben. Okay, also eine hundertprozentige Richtigkeit kann so ein System nicht garantieren. Was gibt es noch für Schranken?
Also ich finde zum Beispiel, eine Schranke ist ja auch, dass der Mensch nicht mal 100% richtig erkennen kann, was ein anderer Mensch meint. Das heißt, es gibt so eine ungefähre Zahl, so 80-90% der Texte wird vom Mensch richtig erkannt. Das heißt, findet der irgendwas gut, ist da vielleicht irgendwie eine Fehlinterpretation drin und besser als der Mensch kann ja mein System auch nicht werden, weil das System muss ja das lernen, was der Mensch ihm so reingibt. Das heißt, so eine klassische Hi-Fi-Aufgabe oder studentische Hilfskraftaufgabe ist, eine riesige Anzahl von Texten zu nehmen und die in irgendeiner Weise zu analysieren und zu sagen, was in dem Text drin steckt. Und wenn die eben Fehler machen, dann kriegt die Maschine ja schon fehlerhaftes Material, um zu lernen. Und dann kann ja auch die Maschine nicht 100%ig erkennen, was richtig ist.
Okay, aber dann sagen Sie, wir sind wieder bei dem Punkt, dass es sozusagen keine hundertprozentige Sicherheit gibt in den Ergebnissen, die unser System ausspuckt.
Aber es geht tatsächlich schon viel mehr, als man gemeinten glaubt. Also es gibt funktionierende Systeme, die zum Beispiel alle laufenden Fernsehprogramme die Tonspur in Text verwandeln, also aus dem gesprochenen Wort, geschriebenes Wort machen und das dann auch live übersetzen. Die Qualität der Übersetzung ist ungefähr dann so wie Google Translate. Also man kann sich da nicht wirklich drauf verlassen. Aber, und das ist das generelle Vorgehen, es reicht aus, um sozusagen Verdachtsmomente zu sammeln, Stichworte zu erzeugen und einfach einen menschlichen Analysten dazu zu bringen, sich das mal anzugucken. Also diese ganze Computergeschichte, die sorgt am Ende nur dafür, dass die Arbeitsleistung für die menschlichen Analysten, die am Ende da immer noch sitzen, sinkt, dass sie sich nur noch das angucken müssen, wo der Computer sozusagen gesagt hat, das ist verdächtig.
Okay, da kommen wir gleich noch zu. Genau. So, jetzt haben wir tatsächlich einen Anrufer. Wenn ihr Fragen habt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen, 0331779110, falls ihr euch an irgendeiner Stelle zu schnell geht. Zu langsam nicht, weil das soll heute wirklich jeder verstehen können, aber wenn es euch zu schnell geht, könnt ihr gerne anrufen und nachfragen. Und André hat angerufen, 29, aus Lübeau, und hat eine Frage jetzt nichts mit Text zu tun, sondern mit Bewegung. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir dir da heute weiterhelfen können. Wir versuchen es mal. Hallo André.
Naja, nee, die hat sich eigentlich schon geklärt, wie lange halten eigentlich digitale Daten?
Wie lange halten digitale Daten? Naja, also prinzipiell erstmal für immer. Aber vielleicht, Simon, kannst du das sagen, wenn man mit großen Datenmengen arbeitet. Ich bin ja so ein Mensch, ich mache ja viel Audio. Meine Krankheit ist sozusagen, von Projekten, die ich mache, hebe ich immer alles auf. Und so Audio-Rohaufzeichnungen sind wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr groß. Ich kaufe mir also häufiger mal neue Festplatten. Das war eben gerade so, wenn man so große Datenmengen verarbeitet und die halt irgendwie analysiert, hält man dann heutzutage das Ergebnis auf und spreche das ab? Oder sagt man sich, ach komm, die Platte kostet irgendwie ein Fünfer, die Rohdaten heben wir auch gleich auf?
Also ich erstmal kommt es darauf an, was für eine Information man überhaupt extrahieren will. Wenn es jetzt wirklich gerade um aktuelle Dinge geht, dann hält man sich die Daten für die letzten drei Monate oder drei Wochen. Daten, die im großen Stil gesammelt werden über längere Zeit, werden häufig auch gefiltert. Das heißt Informationen werden daraus extrahiert, die einerseits verarbeitet gespeichert werden und es werden Informationen weggeworfen. Das heißt die Daten werden quasi ausgefiltert, die höchstwahrscheinlich nicht relevant sind für eine Analyse. Um quasi das Rauschen rauszufiltern an der Stelle.
Ich versuche mir mal ein Beispiel auszudenken, so was wie, wenn ich mir, bebeide mal beim Beispiel Tweets, wenn ich mir sozusagen alle Tweets aufschreibe, dann merke ich mir möglicherweise nicht die Sekunden, wann der Tweet gestellt wurde, weil für mich ist es egal. Ich will dann ungefähr die Tageszeit wissen und spare damit ein bisschen Speicherplatz. In der Richtung?
Ich würde eher sagen, gesamte Tweets. Also wirklich dann sagen, diese Zahl kleiner zu machen, das gibt nicht den gewünschten Effekt. Sondern eher Tweets, die höchstwahrscheinlich nicht relevant sind für meine Analyse. An diesem Ansatz wird eher gearbeitet, dass ich sagen kann, die Daten filtre ich raus, die brauche ich nicht mehr.
Also da wissen wir von Snowden ja tatsächlich auch schon ein bisschen mehr. Und zwar ist es so, dass der komplette Internetverkehr, also da wo er angezapft wird, drei Tage aufgehoben wird, drei Tage zum Abruf zur Verfügung steht und dann weggeworfen wird, es sei denn einer der Selektoren hat gegriffen. Also es gibt da so Suchbegriffe, nach denen durchsucht wird, was auch mal eine Telefonnummer sein kann oder eine IP-Adresse oder bestimmte Schlüsselwörter, dann wird er aufgehoben. Also sozusagen drei Tage alles und dann danach das, wo irgendein System gesagt hat, das ist relevant.
Okay, Adrian, hat er seine Frage beantwortet? Sehr schön, dann viel Spaß noch.
Danke.
Ich glaube, was ein sehr interessanter Aspekt an dieser ganzen Sache ist, weil Andreas auch gerade meinte, eine bestimmte Telefonnummer oder ein bestimmtes Keyword, es ist nicht so, dass da irgendjemand sitzt und diese Keywords eingibt. Das macht niemand explizit. Das ist auch der Trick oder das, was man verstehen muss an der ganzen Sache, ist, dass diese Algorithmen, diese Computer nicht explizit programmiert werden. Sondern es werden Programme geschrieben, die smart genug sind, um diese Keywords, diese Telefonnummern zu finden. Und das dann natürlich dann auch im ganz, ganz großen Stil machen können.
Also da auch wieder sowohl als auch die Telefonnummer von Frau Merkel stand explizit auf dieser Suchliste von Keywords nach ihr gesucht wird. Aber es gibt auch das andere, nämlich die Algorithmen, in denen man sagt, pass mal auf, böse funktionieren so und so, such uns mal alle, die böse sind. Es gab das ein wunderschönes Beispiel in der Dokumentation einer Software, die Cluster-Analyse macht, die also tatsächlich als Beispiel einer Terrorzelle der RAF genommen hat. Wurde modelliert, so sieht das aus, hier irgendwie klar. Und wir auch immer haben miteinander und kennen sich und haben telefoniert und sich getroffen. Und suchen wir mal Leute, die sich ähnlich verhalten. Und dann ploppen dann plötzlich Namen und Telefonnummern von anderen Leuten raus, die sich so ver- Terroristen.
Ah ja, wie man dazu kommt, wie man Daten genau analysiert und wie man sozusagen auch völlig vollautomatisch Leute verdächtig machen kann, das kennen wir gleich. Wir hören jetzt eine kurze Musik hier im Chaos Radio und danach geht es mit Joachim Scharloth weiter, der mal ein bisschen darüber erzählt, wie man eigentlich Textanalyse mit Maschinen macht. Das sind Sachen, die hatte ich eigentlich schon anders geplant. Manchmal ist es schiefgegangen, aber immerhin habt ihr noch mal live gehört, dass es das Chaos Radio ist, sowohl an einem Opener als auch an einem chaotischen Einstieg, den wir euch gerade hier gegeben haben. Das Chaos Radio ist die Sendung, wo der Chaos Computer Club mit Freunden zu Gast ist und Dinge erklärt, die irgendwas mit Technik zu tun haben. Heute besprechen wir mal, wie das eigentlich ist mit der Datenanalyse. Die Geheimdienste haben diese riesigen Mengen Daten von uns und wissen alles, zumindest theoretisch, weil sie haben diese großen Daten, aber da muss man ja irgendwie auch durchwarten und wie das geht und dass man das halt nicht von Hand machen kann, ist ja klar. Wir wollen aber heute mal klären, was da eigentlich derzeit so möglich ist. Wir haben in der ersten Stunde geklärt, dass es da schon verschiedene Gebiete gibt, wo sich verschiedene Leute schon Gedanken gemacht haben. Und das kann man noch so erklären, dass dann selbst Leute, die überhaupt keine Ahnung haben, sagen so, hmm, möglicherweise ist dann diese Überwachungsparanoia doch was dran. Das hat uns Anna Biselli erklärt. Dann haben wir darüber geredet, wie ist es eigentlich, wenn man so Hardware und Software baut, um große Datenmengen zu analysieren? Das hat Simon Willnauer gemacht. Und wir haben festgestellt, das ist schon teuer, aber das ist nicht unvorstellbar. Also es ist so, man muss halt da schon irgendwie so ein bisschen viel Geld reinpumpen, wenn man da große, große Datenmengen bearbeiten will. Aber es geht. Es geht vor allem für richtig große Firmen oder für Geheimdienste, die möglicherweise mehrere Milliarden Budget haben. Und jetzt wollen wir den ganzen noch die Krone aufsetzen und mal mit jemandem sprechen, der sich damit beschäftigt, wie man Texte genau analysiert. Ja, also die ganzen Nachrichten, das ist ja so die Idee heute. Also alle eure Texte liegen irgendwo rum. Aber was macht man dann damit? Joachim Scharloth, das Lingo ist, beschäftigt sich damit. Hallo nochmal.
Hallo.
Und so, die erste Frage, die ich hier stellen möchte, ist, es gibt diese Idee, diese ganzen Buchstaben, die wir ins Internet schreiben, das ist einfach viel zu viel, um alles zu analysieren. Gibt es ein zu viel, wenn man Texte analysieren will?
Also es gibt natürlich Verarbeitungsgrenzen, aber von Interesse her eigentlich nicht. Also mein Traum ist natürlich, die Volltextdatenbank über alle jemals entstandenen Texte, das wäre natürlich großartig. Aber entscheidend ist ja, dass man aus diesen Texten Muster lernen lässt. Und je mehr Texte man hat, desto besser kristallisieren sich die Muster heraus. Und ja, auch desto besser kann man vielleicht auch sehen, was denn Abweichungen, einzelne Abweichungen von großen Musterclustern sind zum Beispiel.
Warte mal, also sagen, ich werfe erstmal den Text rein, ohne irgendwas dazu zu sagen und der Computer sucht erstmal raus, wie gleichen die sich. Kann man machen. Okay.
Aber es hängt natürlich immer von der Fragestellung ab. Also es hängt immer davon ab, was ich eigentlich wissen will, was ich dann auch sozusagen auf diese Texte loslasse. Es gibt natürlich so ein paar Standardverfahren, denke ich, die immer wieder vorkommen, also dass man irgendwie erst mal guckt, was sind denn wichtige Wörter in bestimmten Texten, was sind zum Beispiel auch dann Named Entities, also was sind irgendwie Orte, Organisationen, Personen, die in diesen Texten vorkommen. Das kann man alles automatisch natürlich erkennen lassen. Das ist zum Teil eben abhängig auch von den Sprachen. Also es gibt sozusagen sprachspezifische Algorithmen, die uns dabei helfen, diese Sachen zu erkennen. Und man kann dann eben weitergehen. Also je nachdem, was einen interessiert, kann man sagen, wir gucken uns eben Kollokationen an. Wir hatten schon davon gesprochen.
Nicht so schnell, nicht so schnell.
Typische Wortverbindungen.
Okay, also du hast ja auf dem Chaos-Kongress auch einen Vortrag gehalten über diese, sagen, Textverarbeitung. Und wenn man mit dir spricht, ist es also eine der Fingerübungen, scheinen ja zu sein, herauszufinden, wer überhaupt ein Text geschrieben hat.
Ja, also das ist ein Hobby. Nein, also wir hatten es vorher mit Multunimität, macht das Sinn, irgendwie mehrere Identitäten im Netz zu pflegen oder, also wenn man eben sich möglichst unsichtbar machen will. Also eine Gegenmaßnahme dagegen ist natürlich, dass man sagt, ja gut, wir versuchen jetzt Autoren zu identifizieren, indem wir ihre Sprache angucken und nach gemeinsamen Features suchen, die sozusagen alle ihre sprachliche Äußerungen in allen Kontexten haben und so die Anonymität aufzuheben oder zumindest zu lockern, um es mal so zu sagen. Ja, das macht man, indem man Texte nach wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr vielen Merkmalen beschreibt. Also das sind zum Teil Merkmalsvektoren, die haben 300, 400, 500 Merkmale drin. Also da sind auch so absurde Sachen drin, wie irgendwie, wie viele Wörter haben weniger als fünf Buchstaben beispielsweise. Aber auch andere Sachen, wie hoffe ich benutze jemand Konjunktiv, wie hoffe ich benutze jemand irgendwie Das-Sätze. Also eine ganz komplexe Beschreibung dieser Texte. Und dann kann man eben sagen, also Vektoren, die sich irgendwie stark ähneln, die Texte müssen dann von einem gleichen Autor sein. Das sind natürlich Zuschreibungen. Ich denke, ich bin ja Soziolinguist eigentlich vom Hause aus, also ich beschäftige mich irgendwie, wie Gesellschaft Sprache prägt und wie gesellschaftliche Praktiken Sprache prägen. Wir wissen natürlich, dass Textsorten einen ganz entscheidenden Einfluss haben, darauf wie Sprache aussieht. Also das heißt, wenn wir alle hier in diesem Studio ein Erpresserschreiben schreiben, dann ähneln sich das dieses Erpresserschreiben sprachlich wahrscheinlich eben, also die ähneln sich mehr, als wenn wir irgendwie unser Erpresserschreiben oder dein Erpresserschreiben mit deinen E-Mails vergleichen. Weil einfach die, wir orientieren uns immer an sozialen Mustern, wenn wir Texte schreiben und das macht die Sache halt ein bisschen schwierig. Auch wenn Informatiker uns manchmal Glauben machen wollen, das sei gar nicht so schwer und eigentlich sei das alles gleich, aber es ist nicht so ganz einfach, ja.
Okay, also das heißt, es geht oder es geht nicht?
Also es gibt natürlich experimentelle Settings, in denen das ganz gut funktioniert, aber ich weiß auch aus eigener Erfahrung und auch aus Leuten, die damit professionell arbeiten, dass es mit authentischen Falldaten sehr viel schlechter aussieht.
Also sagen, wenn man jetzt einen bestimmten Text nimmt und dann so denkt, okay, ich möchte jetzt wissen, wer den geschrieben hat, dann ist es schwierig, das wirklich mit Sicherheit zu sagen. Ja, okay, aber man kann es versuchen, kriegt eine Idee davon. Wie ist denn das, wenn man in einem eingeschränkten Gebiet arbeitet? Also sagen, wenn man nicht sagt, okay, irgendwie ganz Deutschland ein Text, wer war das? Aber wenn man sagt, irgendwie so Umfeld von 50 Leuten, ist es dann einfacher oder ist es dann schwieriger?
Grundsätzlich viel einfacher, also aber es hängt davon ab, wie stark sich die Leute unterscheiden in den Texten, ja. Also aber es ist auf jeden Fall sehr viel einfacher, ja. Und man würde es auch gar nicht machen, also ein Text ganz Deutschland, das wäre ziemlich sinnlos, weil man hat Hypothesen und die sollte man eher testen und nicht so völlig datengeleitet davon gehen.
Okay, da geht es dann eher schon darum, dass man sagt, okay wir haben schon einen bestimmten Verdacht, ob wir mal reingehen. Wie ist es denn mit dieser anderen Sache? Also weil wir wollen heute eher über diese ganz großen Sachen. Was kann man denn da in dieser Richtung machen? Das heißt sagen, wir haben jetzt irgendwie hier alle Daten, also Texte von allen Leuten, was kann man denn da rausfinden?
Ja, was willst du denn rausfinden?
Moment mal, so war das nicht geplant.
Ja, das ist die entscheidende Frage, die wir erstmal beantworten müssen.
Also ich kann es so persönlich sagen. Persönlich ist es so, ich twitter zum Beispiel und ich denke, dass ich sozusagen, also mir ist schon klar, dass wenn man meinen Twitter liest, dass man dann von einer Vorstellung davon bekommt, wer ich bin, weil das natürlich in einer gewissen Art und Weise, auch wenn ich nicht über alles twittere, was mich bewegt oder was mein Leben ausmacht, lernt man da doch, wie ich zum Beispiel, usw. usf. Trotzdem denke ich, ich bin jetzt nicht unbedingt die Person, also die da auf Twitter ist. Das ist halt die Frage. Also wenn ich so jetzt die Twitter, also alle Tweets von einer einzelnen Person, von jemanden, mit dem ich mich analysiere, weiß ich dann zum Beispiel sowas wie, wie er drauf ist? Also sag ich jetzt mal ganz...
Wenn du es wissen willst, wie er drauf ist, dann kannst du entsprechende Algorithmen schaffen. Also ich, ich, Entschuldigung, dass ich dir jetzt so ausweiche, aber ich finde, du, also die Frage geht meiner Meinung nach in die falsche Richtung, weil Daten werden immer mit einem bestimmten Ziel analysiert. Ja und je nach dem Ziel baue ich mir meinen, meinen Untersuchungsdesign oder irgendwie meine Algorithmen und die kann ich besser und schlechter bauen. Und ich glaube, man kann jetzt nicht so, also wenn du jetzt sagst, wir sollen deinen Charakter analysieren aufgrund deiner Twitter-Daten. Okay, dann bauen wir uns ein Modell und sagen, okay dein Charakter hat, also oder sozusagen aus der Psychologie nehmen wir irgendwie, Charakter hat irgendwie so und so viele Dimensionen, fünf Dimensionen, die Big Five. Und dann gucken wir, wie wir die eben sprachlich irgendwie abbilden können. Dann formulieren vielleicht Hypothesen, dass sich Emotionalität in bestimmten Wörtern und Wortverbindungen zeigt und dass wir die, wenn wir die besonders häufig finden, dann schreiben wir die eben zu, dass du ein emotionaler Mensch bist. So würden wir vielleicht vorgehen. Aber so ganz ohne Wissen baut keiner solche Systeme und auch nicht ganz ohne so ein konkretes Analyseziel. Und in dieses Analyseziel und in diese Konzepte geht eben ganz viel Weltwissen ein. Und ganz viele auch Machtpositionen. Also was ein Geheimdienst denkt, was ein Terrorist ist oder sowas, das definiert eben er. Und darüber gibt es keinen gesellschaftlichen Diskurs und sowas, sondern das ist eine Definition, die dort gemacht wird und dann, ja.
Also vielleicht hilft es mal ein Beispiel anzugucken für real existierende Systeme, die tatsächlich automatisiert Texte auswerten und auf der Basis davon Entscheidungen zu treffen. Und zwar an der Börse gibt es ja Pflichtinformationen, die die notierten Unternehmen veröffentlichen müssen. Und diese werden automatisiert ausgewertet. Und auf Grundlage dieser Informationen werden Kauf- und Verkaufsentscheidungen getroffen. Das heißt, was man hat, was reinkommt, sind diese sogenannten Ad-hoc-Meldungen, die den Vorteil haben, dass sie eine sehr, sehr formale, kodifizierte Sprache haben. Also hast du keine große Variationsbreite, sondern das sind alles Standardsätze, die ähnliche Formulierungen haben, bestimmte Schlüsselwörter, die immer gleich funktionieren. Auf der anderen Seite musst du nun eine sehr einfache Entscheidung treffen, nämlich kaufen oder verkaufen. Und das funktioniert tatsächlich, das ist im Einsatz. Und wenn so eine Ad-hoc-Meldung draußen ist, innerhalb von Millisekunden sind die Algorithment-Trading-Systeme dabei und kaufen und verkaufen die Aktien auf Grundlage dieser Informationen.
Haben Sie schon jemanden reich gemacht? Außer demjenigen, der die Software geschrieben hat?
Na, derjenige, der die Software schreibt, das sind in der Regel die großen Aktienhäuser. Also tatsächlich werden mittlerweile 70 Prozent des gesamten Handels automatisiert abgewickelt. Das sind also nicht nur diese Ad-hoc-Analysesysteme. Da gab es einen ganz großartigen Fall. Da wurde nämlich, Twitter wird übrigens auch ausgewertet. Also das sind die Leute, die sich mal eben die paar hundert Rechner hinstellen, um Twitter in Echtzeit auszuwerten. Da wurde ein Twitter-Account übernommen von irgendeinem Hacker, irgendwas Großes, ich glaube irgendeine Nachrichtenmagazine, CNN oder sowas und zwei, drei falsche Informationen getwittert und plötzlich haben die angefangen, Aktien zu kaufen, verkaufen automatisiert. Also in den Stellen geht das dann halt schief. Aber tatsächlich verdienen die echten Haufen Geld und dominieren mittlerweile das Börsengeschäft mit solchen automatisierten Systemen.
Wow, ich glaube, die spannende Frage wäre nicht, wer damit reich geworden ist, sondern wie viel Börsencrest dadurch schon verunstaltet wurden.
Dazu machen wir mal eine ganz eigene Frage, das ist ein hochspannendes Thema.
Okay, über sekundlichen Börsenhandel. Joachim, zurück zu dir. Möglicherweise stelle ich die falschen Fragen, weil du, ich kenne dich sozusagen, man kennt dich aus dem Chaos-Umfeld, weil du halt Vorträge über diese Textanalyse-Möglichkeiten hältst und da erklärst, was geht. Was geht denn? Du hast ja auch ein Beispiel mitgebracht. Also wovor, oder andersrum, wovor muss man sich denn fürchten bei dieser Überwachung? Oder was wird da versucht?
Vor den Überwachern muss man sich fürchten. Warum muss man sich fürchten? Ich finde, wir sollten vielleicht erst mal so aufbauen, was man sich alles angucken kann in Texten. Also wir haben ja so irgendwelche Terme oder Keywords, wir haben vielleicht auch Named Entities. Dann machen wir Kollokationen, wir gucken uns an, was sind typische Wortverbindungen.
Okay, warte, warte, warte. Also Named Entities, das heißt sozusagen, es ist kein Problem, dass ich einem Computer beibringe zu sagen, okay, das und das sind Namen, damit sind Personen gemeint. Oder Orte oder Markennamen oder was auch immer man sich da ausdenkt. Das sind also das, wenn du Named Entity sagst, dann hat man irgendeine Kategorie gefunden, das und das sind so. Okay, Kollokationen, noch mal ein spannendes, genauer kleines, also Worte, die zusammen auftreten.
Ja, also nicht Worte, die zufällig zusammen auftreten, sondern sogar Worte, die eben überzufällig häufig zusammen auftreten. Also wo man eben sagen kann, wenn man so denkt, die werden zufällig verteilt, dann könnte man eine bestimmte Frequenz annehmen, aber die treten eben sehr viel häufiger auf, als diese zufällige Verteilung uns nahelegen würde. Also das heißt, es sind typische Wortverbindungen. Und du hast gesagt, ich hab was vorbereitet. Also wir haben gerade vor der Sendung ein bisschen rumgerechnet. Und da konnten wir zum Beispiel feststellen, Islambrüderschaft haben wir uns angeguckt, den deutschen Blog. Und international ist zum Beispiel dort, sind Kollokationen sind israelisch, Verfolgung, Gemeinschaft, Konferenz, Regierung und so weiter. Bei der RAF, die wir uns auch angeguckt haben, da ist es imperialistisch, Kampf, Klassenkrieg, Westeuropa. Und bei Angela Merkel ist es Finanzkrise, Staat und Gemeinschaft bindend. Und man kann sozusagen, wenn man all diese Kollokationen zusammen nimmt, kann man Profile erstellen. Also das heißt, man kann Profile erstellen, welche typischen Wortverbindungen ein Mensch hat. Du zum Beispiel in deinen Moderationen, ich in meinen Aufsätzen, der Andi in seinen Radio-Moderationen und Blogbeiträgen. Und auf die Weise kann man natürlich erstens Themen identifizieren. Man kann aber auch gegebenenfalls auch, je nachdem um welche Wortverbindungen es sich handelt, welche man da anschaut, kann man auch Autorinnen und Autoren identifizieren damit.
Also das ist dann aber quasi so eine Art, also man macht das einmal und dann weiß man etwas und dann kann man in Zukunft sagen, gucken wo das noch auftaucht.
Das wäre eine Möglichkeit daran zu gehen, zu sagen okay, wir wissen die RAF war Terroristen und jetzt wollen wir mal gucken, gibt es denn heute auch solche Leute wie die RAF, die genauso solche Theorien vertreten und die wahrscheinlich mit dem ähnlichen Überzeugungsgrad codieren, weil wir vielleicht dann denken, das sind vielleicht potenzielle Gefährder und dann würde man eben tatsächlich von den Texten der RAF lernen, Muster lernen und würde gucken, wo findet man die denn, nicht auf Twitter, aber irgendwo.
Das ist auch eine spannende Frage. Wie lange muss denn so ein Text sein, damit ich ihn sinnvoll mit anderen Sachen vergleichen kann? Gibt es dann eine gewisse Länge?
Ja, damit man sinnvoll Kolokationen berechnen kann, braucht es schon ein bisschen mehr Text, finde ich.
Und wenn man das Ergebnis einmal hat, reichen dann auch sozusagen?
Dann reichen auch wenige.
Dann reichen auch wenige, okay. Also man braucht einmal sozusagen viel, um anzufangen, aber dann kann man so, okay. Was ich mich jetzt immer frage, ist, also das klingt für mich alles so, ich kann zwar Programme schreiben, die sind auch beliebig komplex, aber die sind letztlich auch nicht mehr. Das sind halt nur komplexe Wörterbücher. Oder kann man tatsächlich?
Das ist natürlich mehr als Wörterbücher, ja. Also eben, wir können Themen lernen, also mit Topic Modeling können wir bestimmte Themenkombinationen feststellen. Wir können gucken, wir hängen Themen zusammen. Wir werden die Inteksen verknüpft. Also man kann schon eine ganze Menge mehr machen als sozusagen ein reines Wörterbuch haben. Also wir können zum Beispiel, wenn wir uns jetzt dann doch RAV-Texte angucken, stellen wir zum Beispiel fest, dass irgendwie, ich hab das mal durchgerechnet, gefangene Forderung, Freilassung, Zusammenlegung, Freiheit, Isolation, Hungerstreik, Kollektiv und so weiter bilden ein Thema. Also das heißt, der Algorithmus stellt fest, dass in Texten diese Wörter, wenn man sie gewichtet hat, signifikant häufig zusammen auftreten und deswegen ein Thema ausmachen müssen. Und dieses Thema kann man in vielen Texten wiederum feststellen. Und also man kann wirklich schon relativ viel machen, man kann eben, wie wir ganz am Anfang gehört haben, man kann die Haltung zu diesen Themen messen. Aber wie ich schon versucht habe zu erklären, Texte haben keine so eindeutig festgelegte Bedeutung. Sie haben sie nie. Also weil sie sind, also schon der Autor, die Autorin gibt dem Text keine eindeutige Bedeutung, hat beim Widerlesen jeder den Text immer wieder anders. Und was die Leserinnen und Leser betrifft sowieso und all diesen Dingen wird die computergesteuerte Analyse natürlich nicht vollständig gerecht und auch überhaupt nicht gerecht eigentlich, denn wir haben eigentlich den Anspruch, dass wenn wir den Text zweimal mit dem gleichen Algorithmus analysieren, dass es auch das gleiche herauskommt.
Das hätte ich jetzt erwartet, ja.
Aber wenn wir zweimal den Text lesen, kommt zweimal was anderes raus.
Also für die Schülerinnen und Schülern und Zuhörern, wenn ihr im Deutschunterricht gefragt werdet, was wollte der Autor uns damit sagen, ist die einzige zulässige Antwort, das weiß ich auch nicht. Ich kann nur analysieren, was er geschrieben hat.
So, und dann sagen, wenn ich das zweimal mache, kommt möglicherweise ein Unterschied raus, bei Computer kommt immer dasselbe raus und das ist eigentlich der Teil des Problems.
Wahrscheinlich nochmal was drittes unterschiedliches, das ist das Teil des Problems, ja.
Aber das kommt dann immer wieder raus.
Genau, da sind wir jetzt bei der Kommunikationstheorie, dass Kommunikation zwingt, ein Sender und ein Empfänger und ein Kanal dazwischen voraussetzt und es nicht unbedingt gegeben ist, dass irgendwie Sender und Empfänger dieselbe Kodierung verwenden.
Ja, aber liebe Leute, wenn man das jetzt als gegebenenhin mir kann man sagen, können wir diesen ganzen Quatsch auch gleich sparen. Warum macht man es denn?
Ja, es geht an der Stelle wirklich um banalere Fragestellungen, um diese Topic Modeling zurückzukommen. Es geht wirklich darum, ein sogenanntes Modell zu schaffen, mit dem ich eine Frage beantworten kann. Die Fragen sind relativ einfach. Die Fragen sind, ist dieses Dokument gefährlich für mich oder nicht? Und das kann ich jetzt eben auf genau meine Gefahr hintrainieren. Und das ist mir darum sehr, sehr schwer abhängig von, wer du bist und was du wissen willst. Ist es gefährlich für meinen Staat? Ist es gefährlich für meine Firma, für meine Familie? Das sind am Ende des Tages wirklich eine Ja- oder Nein-Frage. Und diese Ja- oder Nein-Frage wird mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit beantwortet. Und wenn diese Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch genug ist, dann sollte sich jemand das wirklich mal angucken. Und darum geht es an einem Tag.
Das ist wie bei Casablanca, da sagt dann am Ende einer, round up the usual suspects. Und einer von den Szenen ist es dann, wo der Algorithmus gesagt hat, irgendwie da guckt er mal genauer hin. Oder zumindest ist es die Vorstellung, die da in den Köpfen existiert.
Aber also wenn man euch so hört, dann würden jetzt die Leute, die sagen, ich hab doch nichts zu verbergen, automatisch Recht bekommen. Weil tatsächlich ist es ja so, wenn sie sozusagen, wenn sie nichts Böses gemacht haben, dann tauchen sie sowieso nicht auf in der verdächtigen Gruppe. Und selbst wenn sie auftauchen, ist es ja nicht so schlimm, weil sie werden dann ja nochmal von den Menschen kontrolliert und dann sozusagen wieder aussortiert, weil sie da doch nicht verdächtigt waren. Also ist das mit Überwachung eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm?
Na genau, das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Also gerade die Tatsache, dass diese Auswertung nicht so verlässlich funktioniert, heißt, dass es Faults Positives gibt. Also dass Leute betroffen sind, die tatsächlich, also nichts zu verbergen. Also wer hat schon nichts zu verbergen? Also zumindest der Mannung ist, dass es nicht nichts zu Schulden hat kommen lassen, wo dann plötzlich Drohnen rumfliegen und einen erschießen könnten. Trotzdem Opfer davon werden, dass eine Drohne kommt und einen erschießt und dass in Probleme kommen. Also Brasil, die wunderschöne, da wird der Buchstabe verwechselt, dann lautet der Haftbefehl auf den Falschen und dann landet er im Knast. Also genau das ist die Folge davon, dass solche Analysen eben nie perfekt sein können.
Und das muss man hinzufügen, wir wissen nicht, was uns zugeschrieben wird. Also wir wissen nicht, wonach gesucht wird, weil das sich eben im Raum abspielt, der sozusagen zur Schutzlogik dazugehört. Die Logik der Überwachung ist etwas, das geheim bleiben muss, weil dann funktioniert sie nämlich nicht mehr, wenn sie öffentlich würde.
Du kannst dich nicht mal unauffällig verhalten, weil du weißt nicht, was unauffällig ist.
Richtig. Jetzt komme ich da nicht mehr hinterher. Also weil ihr habt ja gerade erklärt, es gibt diese Systeme, aber die funktionieren nicht so richtig zuverlässig. Das heißt ja eigentlich, die Systeme sind egal und dann habt ihr jetzt gesagt, man kann sich aber nicht vor den Systemen schützen, weil man weiß nicht, wie sie funktionieren.
Wir haben nicht gesagt, dass es egal ist.
Weil sie sind ja nicht konsequenzlos. Da laufen ja die Jungs mit dem Maschinengewehr los, je nachdem, was diese Systeme gesagt haben. Das ist doch der Punkt dabei. Dass sie nicht hundertprozentig funktionieren, ist das Problem. Das ist nämlich genau das Problem, dass halt die Jungs mit dem Maschinengewehren möglicherweise zu den Falschen kommen, nämlich zu dir, weil du aus Versehen mit demselben Muster telefoniert hast, wie die Terroristen auch.
Also ich glaube, das Problem ist, dass die Leute mit dem Maschinengewehren kommen. Davon abgesehen, es wäre schlimm, wenn diese Systeme hundertprozentig funktionieren würden. Nee, aber die Frage, die Simon gestellt hat, ist, wer stellt denn die Fragen, mit welchen Interessen? Und das sind eben vielleicht nicht die Interessen, die man als Bürger oder Bürgerin hat. Und wir dürfen nicht die Fragen mitstellen. Wir wissen gar nicht, was die Fragen sind. Und das macht das Ganze zum Problem.
Ich glaube auch, wenn man mal ein anderes Beispiel nimmt, das nicht gerade so eine großräumige Polizeieüberwachung oder so nimmt, kann man die ganze Sache auch noch weiter treiben. Also was ich so bei der Recherche gefunden habe, war eine ganz gruselige Firma von meiner Seite aus Aachen, die nennt sich PsiWare, was auch schon mal gut klingt, so wie SpyWare. Und die haben irgendwie eine Software gemacht für Text oder auch Sprachanalyse, die sie verkaufen an Unternehmen, die Bewerber einstellen wollen, an Krankenkassen und an Polizei. Das heißt, sie sagen zum Beispiel den Unternehmen, die die Bewerberauswahl machen wollen, wir können ihnen dabei helfen, Bewerber herauszufinden, die besonders leistungsfähig sind und die besonders gut für ihr Unternehmen geeignet sind. Das machen sie eben, indem sie einfach diese Software über Bewerbungsunterlagen darüber laufen lassen und dann einfach auch die raussortieren, die wahrscheinlich nicht den Anforderungen gerecht werden. Oder bei dieser Krankenkassengeschichte bieten sie eine Telefon-Hotline an, da kann der Mensch dann anrufen und prüfen lassen, ob er psychisch gestört ist. Das heißt, sie sagen, psychisch gestört oder verängstigte Menschen haben eine bestimmte Wortwahl und in dem Fall auch noch eine bestimmte Sprachfrequenz oder ein bestimmtes Sprachverhalten. Und dann können wir eben sagen, dieser Mensch hat wahrscheinlich irgendeine psychische Auffälligkeit. Und das ist halt der Bobett, wo man richtig das Gruseln bekommt. Weil wenn man das, also wenn man so analysiert wird, ohne dass man das weiß, dann kann es ja noch ganz andere Konsequenzen haben. Dass dann vielleicht die Krankenkasse, bei der man nur anrufen will, um einzutreten, dass sie dann plötzlich sagt, nee, wollen wir nicht, weil sie sind ja vielleicht irgendwie psychisch gestört. Und wenn man das nicht mal mitkriegt, dann wird das Ganze ganz absurd. Und die meinen eben auch, sie verkaufen diese Systeme an Versicherungen, um dann eben eine Vorauswahl zu treffen, wer die Versicherung betrügen will. Das heißt, die Versicherung sagt dann aufgrund von einem Gespräch, dass man am Telefon mit ihnen geführt hat, wo man vielleicht ein bisschen nervös war oder ein bisschen aufgeregt, weil gerade das Haus abgebrannt ist. Nee, sie sind auffällig. Das ist wahrscheinlich Versicherungsbetrug. Das sind einfach so Anwendungsfälle, mit denen rechnet man nicht. Die sind jetzt nicht die große Überwachung, wo denn jemand mit dem Maschinengewehr kommt, sondern eine sehr alltägliche Überwachung. Und die Firma hat eben auch gewisse Referenzen und sagt eben ja, zu unseren Kunden gehören zum Beispiel die Actimonda Krankenkasse und eben auch die Polizei Nordrhein-Westfalen. Das heißt, man kann sich so ein bisschen ausmalen, wo das vielleicht noch überall eingesetzt werden könnte.
Das zeigt ja eigentlich auch, dass die Kritik, die Algorithmen funktionieren nicht richtig, eigentlich nicht unser Ziel sein kann. Weil da könnte man immer noch sagen, machen wir die doch besser.
Das ist auch das, was ich jetzt gerade sozusagen im Moment mitnehme.
Ja, also ich finde eben das Argument viel besser, dass wir darüber diskutieren müssen, welche Fragen gestellt werden an diese Software, welche legitim sind, welche wir zulassen wollen als Gesellschaft und welche eben auch nicht. Das finde ich eigentlich die wichtigere Frage. Also was auf unsere Daten, wie die befragt werden dürfen, finde ich eigentlich irgendwie die wichtigere Frage.
Ich finde das auch gleich eine ganz gute Stelle, um mal zu erwähnen, dass es ja nicht nur um den Inhalt der Kommunikation geht, sondern dass das, was allgemein Metadaten genannt wird, also das, wo uns versucht wird, zu beruhigen, wir speichern ja nur die Metadaten in der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, dass das auch sehr, sehr viel aussagt. Das ist also nicht notwendigerweise nur um die Analyse der Texte geht, die man schreibt und dem, was man sagt, sondern auch das, wann man mit wem kommuniziert, schon sehr, sehr viel Aussagekraft hat, wo man sich befindet und so weiter und so fort. Und auch diese Information wird automatisiert ausgewertet. Also auch das kann man zum Beispiel alle Telefongespräche nehmen. Wer hat wen angerufen? Inhalte komplett wegwerfen, weil das ist ja vielleicht dann doch zu viel. Aber die paar hundert Millionen Telefongespräche, die am Tag geführt werden in Deutschland, die bekommt man damit noch in Griff mit dieser Technik, die wir gehört haben, die nicht allzu teuer ist. Und kann dann da zum Beispiel Cluster-Analysen fahren. Also was sind denn Gruppen von Menschen, die irgendwie miteinander zusammenhängen? Und dann kann man sagen, wir wissen, der ist ein Terrorist. Was sind denn so Gruppen, in denen er sich bewegt und dann tauchen plötzlich so 20, 30, 50 Blasen von Leuten auf, die man dann vielleicht mal näher untersuchen kann, wo man dann so eine V-Leute reinschickt und so weiter und so fort. Also auch das ist Resultat von solchen Auswertungen. Auch das ist quasi Massenüberwachung.
Das finde ich eine sehr, sehr, sehr interessante Fragestellung. Weil in dem Moment, wo wir diese Cluster bilden und diesen Clustern auch bestimmte Gruppen zuordnen können, fangen wir an, Leute noch mehr zu überwachen, noch detaillierter Informationen zu sammeln von diesen Menschen, die gar nichts Unrechtes getan haben an der Stelle. Und allein schon die Zuordnung dieses Clusters reicht aus, um diesen Verdacht herzustellen. Das ist die ganz interessante Fragestellung hier, finde ich.
Also solche Algorithmen werden ja auch eingesetzt, zum Beispiel in Banken, um Kredite zu vergeben. Ja, das haben sie mir im Studium mal erzählt, wie man als kleines mittelständisches Unternehmen bei seiner Bank noch einen Kredit bekommt, zufällig von den Menschen, der für die Sparkasse, die Software geschrieben hat, die diese Entscheidung trifft. Also wie die Bilanz ausgewertet wird. Die haben damals noch sehr, sehr viel Wert darauf gelegt, dass sie nur solche Algorithmen verwenden, die auch nachvollziehbar sind. Also in dem Fall waren es sogenannte Entscheidungsbäume. Das heißt, irgendwie wir sehen, irgendwie statistisch gesehen, Leute unter 20 haben größeres Kreditrisiko als Leute über 30. Und du bist unter 20, deswegen kriegst du keinen Kredit. Oder du bist zwar über 30, aber du hast irgendwie ständig dein Konto überzogen, also kriegst du keinen Kredit. Eine nachvollziehbare Argumentation, wo dann hinterher der Sachbeabteil auch noch erklärt, ja, hören sie mal her, gucken sie sich ihre Kreditgeschichte an, ist leider schwierig. Es gibt aber viele Algorithmen, da weiß man hinterher gar nicht mehr, warum etwas passiert ist. Die liefern diese Informationen des Warum nicht mehr mit, die sagen nur noch der da. Die zeigen mit dem Finger auf ein Ergebnis und sagen, der da ist verdächtig. Und warum ist der verdächtig? Sagt er dir irgendwie, na ja, ich hab hier eine riesengroße Matrix mit lauter Zahlen und da ist es irgendwie rausgefallen, dass er verdächtig ist. Das korreliert mit allen anderen, die verdächtig sind in diesem Land.
Also das ist das eigentliche Problem, sagen an der Schleppnetzdatenüberwachung, dass man sagt, man hat eben ganz, ganz viele Daten, die wirft man rein und dann lässt man sozusagen Systeme, die nicht ganz korrekt arbeiten, da drüber laufen und die sagen dann, okay, von dir ausgedachten Merkmalen 1, 2 und 3 sind, diese Leute verdächtig.
Genau, auch nicht mehr nachvollziehbar, wie das eigentlich zustande gekommen ist, also nicht mehr begründbar.
Gleichzeitig hatten wir jetzt das Schufa-Urteil und Schufa ist natürlich genauso eine transparente Organisation, die Daten sammelt und daraufhin Scores erstellt über die Kreditwürdigkeit von Personen und diese Scores machen, also was sie machen, sind natürlich Zuschreibungen auf Menschen. Also wenn man in einem bestimmten Viertel wohnt, ist das ein Malus oder ein Bonus, je nachdem wie solvent die Mitbewohner in diesem Viertel sind und das sind ja Dinge, die haben mit einem selber ja eigentlich gar nichts zu tun im Sinne von der eigenen Individualität oder der eigene Lebensgeschichte, sondern das ist einfach aggregierte Daten, die auf einen selber angewendet werden, ohne dass man sich dagegen wehren könnte und ich finde da sind wir in einem Bereich, der also höchst problematisch ist.
Also das heißt, wenn jemand das Argument sagt, ich habe doch nicht zu verbergen, ist es eigentlich gar kein Argument gegen Überwachung, weil es tatsächlich in den meisten Fällen gar nicht darum geht, jetzt schon ganz konkret in den Einzelnen irgendwas zuzuhängen, sondern der macht sich dadurch, dass er überwacht wird, ist er sozusagen Teil einer, ich sage jetzt mal Statistik, die erstellt wird und damit fällt er dann möglicherweise irgendwo rein, ohne genau zu wissen warum. Das ist sozusagen das Problem an dieser Stelle. Gut, also was haben wir gelernt? Es geht ganz schön viel, aber es arbeitet unkonkret und das Problem ist, dass wir gar nicht genau wissen, was hinter den Kulissen alles passiert und trotzdem möglicherweise deswegen dran sind. Was die Konsequenzen aussehen können, das klären wir gleich. Vorher gibt es erst noch mal die Nachrichten hier im Chaosradio im Blumen und danach machen wir noch eine letzte halbe Stunde weiter.
Neumann. Unter den ganz großen Shooting Stars ist John Newman noch relativ neu.
Präsentiert von Fritz. Immer gute neue Musik.
Um kurz nach halb zwölf.
Formel 1 Rekordweltmeister Michael Schumacher wird aus dem künstlichen Koma geholt. Schumachers Managerin hat heute bestätigt, dass die Narkosemittel jetzt nach und nach reduziert werden. Der Aufwachprozess kann aber sehr lange dauern. Schumacher war kurz vor dem Jahreswechsel beim Skifahren verunglückt. Wegen seiner schweren Hirnverletzungen hatten die Ärzte ihnen ein künstliches Koma versetzt. Bundeswirtschaftsminister Gabriel will die Energiewende nicht alleine gestalten. Der SPD-Politiker hat gesagt, dass er mit den Bundesländern zusammenarbeiten will. Bei der Energiewende gibt es Streit darüber, wie der Umstieg von Atom- und Kohlestrom am besten funktionieren könnte. Gabriel will die Förderung von Windkraftanlagen an Land kürzen und das kritisieren mehrere Bundesländer. Berlin hat das Studium für angehende Lehrer umgemodelt. In Zukunft wird es statt vier nur noch drei Studiengänge geben. Einen für Grundschulen, einen für Sekundarschulen und Gymnasien, sowie einen für berufliche Schulen. Wer Sonderschullehrer werden will, muss zusätzlich das Fachsonderpädagogik belegen. Ein Praxissemester wird eingeführt und das Referendariat wird für alle Lehrämter anderthalb Jahre dauern.
Sport.
Die Basketballer von Alba Berlin haben das Eurocup-Spiel in der Ukraine gewonnen. Bei Jushner gab es ein 68 zu 65 Sieg nach Verlängerung. Das Spiel musste um einen Tag verschoben werden, weil die Berliner bei ihrer Anreise im Schneesturm stecken geblieben waren. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin immer noch überall minus 4, nur Spandau minus 3 Grad, Cottbus und Angermünde minus 5, Potsdam und Falkensee minus 4 Grad. Nachts kann es vereinzelt noch ein bisschen schneien, es kann aber auch anderseits ganz kurzzeitig Sternen klar werden bei Tiefstwerten um minus 8 Grad. Morgen dann viele Wolken, kaum noch Schnee und vor allen Dingen Tauwetter bei Plusgraden plus 5 Grad maximal. Dort verkehrt Berlin 100, der Stadtring in beiden Richtungen immer noch abschnittsweise stockender Verkehr. Mitte die Wilhelmstraße ist zwischen Leipziger Straße und Bärenstraße in beiden Richtungen gesperrt, da ist ein Kran im Einsatz. Brandenburg A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Spreeau. Zwischen Königswusterhausen und Niederlehme steht ein kaputter Laster. A12 Frankfurt Oder Richtung Berlin, zwischen Grenzübergang Frankfurt Oder und Frankfurt Oder Süd, da hat es auf der linken Spur gekracht. Und noch zur S-Bahn, die S2. Bis Betriebsschluss wird der Abschnitt zwischen Blankenfelde und Lichtenrade unterbrochen. Stattdessen fahrende Busse zwischen Lichtenrade und Marienfelde besteht Pendelverkehr im 20-Minuten-Takt. Worum er sagt, gute Fakt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr den Fritz Night Flight von letzter Nacht verpasst habt oder ihn einfach nochmal hören wollt, dann hört ihn doch einfach nochmal. So oft ihr wollt und wann ihr wollt. Eine Woche lang im Musikstream, Musikstream auf fritz.de.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon mit Marcus Richter und natürlich vielen Besuchern, die vom Chaos Computer Club und angeschlossenen Senderanstalten könnte man beinahe sagen kommen. Na ja, Andreas Bogk ist zu Gast vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallo, guten Tag. Joachim Scharloth, hallo, guten Tag. Simon Willnauer, hallo, guten Tag. Und Anna Biselli, hallo, guten Abend. War zumindest vorhin noch da und jetzt, ach hier vielleicht, hallo. Ah, ist immer noch da. War der falsche Regler offen. Chaos Radio, macht seinem Namen alle Ehre. Wir reden heute über Datenanalyse, also was eigentlich passiert mit den ganzen Daten, die die Geheimdienste möglicherweise, man weiß es ja nicht ganz genau, also die deutschen Geheimdienstmitarbeiter sind sich ja auch gar nicht so sicher, dass das wirklich passiert. Also die ganzen Daten, die über uns angelegt worden sind, wie man die analysieren kann. Und es sind zwei Sachen rausgekommen, also A, es geht tatsächlich, also man kann das auch mit viel Geld, also mit mehr Geld als wir wahrscheinlich alle verdienen, aber es geht schon irgendwie einzurichten. Und dann ist das Problem, wie ich jetzt selber gelernt habe, nicht so sehr, dass da konkret Dinge über eine einzelne Person rausgefunden werden, sondern dass da Algorithmen verwendet werden. Und erbrecht mich jetzt bitte anwesende Leute, wenn ich das falsch zusammenfasse. Es gibt also Algorithmen, die laufen über diese gesammelten Daten drüber und tun dann Leute zusammen in eine Gruppe. Und diese Gruppe wird dann möglicherweise verdächtigt. Niemand weiß so genau, was da passiert, weil die Algorithmen mittlerweile so komplex sind oder auch nicht so genau sein können, dass das so eigentlich Magie und Voodoo gleicht.
Ja und nein.
Also was ich verstanden habe ist, die Algorithmen können Dinge rausfinden. Diese Dinge sind aber nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Trotzdem werden sie benutzt, um Leuten Eigenschaften zuzuschreiben, die sie möglicherweise gar nicht haben, z.B. du bist ein Terrorist.
Genau, genau, so ist das glaube ich schon präziser formuliert. Natürlich ist das auch für das Individuum ein Problem, diese Massenüberwachung, weil wenn alle überwacht werden, heißt das, dass auch gegen dich etwas gefunden werden kann, wenn sie dich auf dem Kieke haben. Also wenn erstmal rausgekommen ist, du bist Terrorist, dann gibt es dann natürlich unglaubliche Mengen von Daten, die da rumliegen, um zu gucken, wie schlimm du wirklich bist und wie böse du wirklich bist. Und das ist im Zweifelsfall, keine Ahnung, wenn du nicht Terrorist bist, sondern sagen wir, der politische Gegner des gerade herrschenden Diktators, auch ein Problem für dich. Also das ist dann nichts mehr, wo die Algorithmen das Problem sind, sondern wo die Überwachung das Problem ist.
Also das System würde doch nie jemand missbrauchen.
Na natürlich nicht.
Okay, wir haben noch einen Anrufer tatsächlich, das ist der Mario. Und er hat, Achtung, die Sendung hat internationale Resonanz gefunden. Mario ruft aus den USA an.
Warum rufst du an? Ja, ich würde gerne wissen, ob diese Programme nur eine Quelle überwachen, zum Beispiel SMS oder Twitter oder können diese Programme auch feststellen, dass ich mehrere Chats benutze oder von mehreren Accounts schreibe?
Also wir hatten die Frage sozusagen zu Teilen schon beantwortet. Es lässt sich sozusagen erstmal nicht vor Ort umansch darstellen, aber man kann sozusagen Autoren schafft von Texten tatsächlich versuchen, mehr festzustellen.
Moment, das ist ja nicht das einzige, worüber man Analysen machen kann, also über diese Autoren schafft, sondern auch so über sowas wie Gleichzeitigkeit. Es gibt bei der NSA eine Fraktion, die, wie mein Insider berichtet, die Pokémon-Fraktion genannt wird. Sammeln sie alle, also die wollen einfach alle Daten, alles was anfällt, wollen die haben. Und das heißt natürlich nicht nur SMS, sondern auch alle Chat-Systeme, an die sie ihre Finger kriegen. Und das heißt natürlich insbesondere solche Chat-Systeme, an die einfach ranzukommen sind, weil sie alle über einen zentralen Server laufen, der auch noch bei amerikanischen Firmen steht. Also wenn du bei Yahoo-Chattest oder sowas, kannst du davon ausgehen, dass alles mitgeschnitten wird. Und die Analysen darüber, welche Accounts möglicherweise dieselbe Person sind, laufen dann zum Beispiel über zeitliche Korrelationen. Irgendwie, wann ist der Account online gegangen, wann ist er wieder offline gegangen? Gibt es möglicherweise Überschneidungen in den Leuten, die mit ihnen reden? Und da fallen relativ schnell die zusammengehörigen Accounts raus. Also wenn man sich guckt, die, die sich immer gleichzeitig einloggen, die sich gleichzeitig ausloggen. Und genau solche Suchen sind auch etwas, was sich relativ leicht darstellen lässt. Also wenn wir 100 Milliarden Log-in-Ereignisse in der großen Datenbank haben, zu sagen, finde mal alle raus, die innerhalb von fünf Sekunden passieren. Und dann die sortiert nach der Häufigkeit von Pärchen. Das ist eine typische Suchanfrage, die so ein System darstellen kann. Und da fällt dann raus, wie loggt sich immer da ein mit demselben System. Und deswegen gehören die Accounts zusammen.
Mario, beantwortet das deine Frage?
Eigentlich läuft so etwas anderes hinaus. Wenn ich nun einen bestimmten Chat benutze für Spiele, sind ja, keine Ahnung, Kriegsspiele oder was auch immer so im Internet zu spielen, das ist mit Clan. Wie schwer ist es möglich herauszufinden, dass es sich um ein Spiel handelt in diesem Chat? Oder könnte ein Person aufgrund dessen in einen Raster fallen, dass er ein Terrorist sein könnte, wenn über Co-Ordinaten gesprochen wird, die man angreifen würde, oder ähnliches.
Ich versuche mal deine Frage zu übersetzen. Was ich richtig verstanden habe, ist, du spielst sagen wir nur das Beispiel wegen Counter-Strike und da hältst du dich in einem Chat darüber, da hinten in der Haus-Ecke steht einer, schießt ihn mal bitte in den Kopf. Und deine Frage ist, ob jemand sozusagen, der das automatisch analysiert, unterscheiden kann, ob du da über ein Spiel sprichst oder ob du gerade wirklich jemand in den Kopf schießen willst? Aha, okay, das ist die Frage. So, wir sind also bei zweideutigen Sachen angekommen. Also da hält sich jemand sozusagen über in den Kopf schießen und die Frage ist jetzt, kann das System unterscheiden, ob das zwischen einem Spiel ist oder nicht?
Also es ist natürlich für den, der die Systeme baut und der die Informationen haben will, ja die Frage stellt, von hohem Interesse, dass man diese Unterscheidung treffen kann. Man möchte ja diese sogenannten False Positives, also die Dinge, die angezeigt werden, obwohl sie gar keine echten Treffer sind, gar keine echten Signale sind.
Man möchte den Gamer nicht zum Attentäter machen.
Richtig, genau. Weil das würde ja auch bedeuten, wenn ich jemanden erkenne als einen potenziellen Attentäter, dann muss ich oder dann wird der Staat, der überwachende Himmel und Hölle in Bewegung setzen, um das zu verhindern, was natürlich auch ein sehr, sehr großer Aufwand ist. Und das ist zumindest meines Erachtens nicht von Interesse des Überwachenden. Man möchte ja eine Information haben, die korrekt ist.
Das ist schonmal ein Punkt, auf die Zunge zu gehen, man sagt, dem Staat ist nicht daran gelegen, niemanden falsch zu verdächtigen, sondern er schaut möglicherweise einfach nur den Aufwand.
Du musst die Kosten sehen.
Das sehe ich gerade, genau. So, also das heißt, er ist daran interessiert. Aber ist es dann auch umsitzbar?
Das ist sicherlich auch wieder endlich. Also was sicherlich niemanden beruhigen wird, ist, dass natürlich auch Chats in Computerspielen überwacht werden und möglicherweise sogar mit der Argumentation, naja, das wird benutzt, um Terroristen auszubilden. Das klingt erst mal ein bisschen absurd, bis man herausfindet, dass die Armeen tatsächlich ihre Soldaten an ähnlichen Software trainieren. Also warum soll man nicht auch Häuserkampf und irgendwie sich gegenseitig Deckung in einem Computerspiel trainieren, wenn man irgendwie in Anführungszeichen Terroristen ausbildet? Das Einzige, was einen schützt, ist, dass es so viele Counter-Strike-Spieler gibt, dass man schon irgendwie noch weitere Kriterien braucht, um jemanden wirklich verdächtigen zu können.
Wir haben ja vorhin auch gehört, dass es nicht nur ein Signal gibt, woraufhin eine Entscheidung getroffen wird. Es gibt Hunderte, wenn nicht Tausende. Es gibt viele Algorithmen, die arbeiten mit Zehntausenden von sogenannten Features. Diese Features können ganz einfache Informationen sein. Spielt diese Person Counter-Strike, ja oder nein? Es ist höchst unwahrscheinlich, dass ein Algorithmus eine Entscheidung trifft nur auf der Basis eines solchen Features.
Um ein einfaches Beispiel zu bringen, möglicherweise bringe ich den Algorithmus bei, wenn jemand im Kopf schließt, dann guckt doch mal bitte, ob von derselben IP-Adresse auf einen Counter-Strike-Server zugegriffen wird. Wenn ja, dann ist er vielleicht erst mal raus.
Also nicht konkret so, aber so kann man sich das zumindest vorstellen. Da kommen dann vielleicht noch Sachen dazu, wie macht öfter mal in Afghanistan Urlaub oder was man sonst noch so tun kann, was vielleicht für sich genommen erst mal unverdächtig ist, aber wenn drei, vier, fünf von diesen Faktoren zusammenkommen. Wobei das natürlich auch immer alles Bilder sind, die in den Köpfen der Leute stattfinden, die diese Systeme programmieren, also ihre Vorurteile und Projektion, Narrative quasi darüber, was ein Terrorist ist, projizieren auf diese Daten, um da wieder verdächtig herauszuziehen.
Also um Marius Frage jetzt abschließend zu beantworten, kann man sagen, also im Prinzip haben die Leute, die überwachen, da relativ wahrscheinlich Interesse dran. Man kann es aber nicht genau sagen, ob es ihnen immer gelingt. Also ihr müsst jetzt noch mal sagen, ob das stimmt oder nicht. Ich versuche nur zusammenfassen, was sie sagen. Okay, Mario, dann ist deine Frage beantwortet.
Ja, ich hätte auch noch eine, wenn...
Ich würde jetzt lieber Schluss machen, weil wir sagen, noch eine große konditionierte Konsequenz zu sprechen, nämlich wie wir zu diesem ganzen Zock umgehen. Aber du kannst sie gerne auf chaosradio.ccc.de stellen. Da gibt es einen Blog zur Sendung und vielleicht kann man sie noch beantworten. In dem Fall, was natürlich spannend ist bei Mario, ich fange ja immer sofort an auszudenken, wenn jemand sagt, ja, da sind verschiedene Datenpunkte, die zusammenkommen. Ich meine, er ist halt anscheinend sozusagen jemand aus Deutschland, der in den USA ist. Also und dann noch so Killerspiele. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht gefährlich ist. So, wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit…
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich Sorgen machen.
Okay, nein. Nicht, wenn alles gut geht, das ist ja, da sind wir bei dem Punkt genau. Jetzt zum Schluss noch, Joachim, du hast mal sozusagen davon gesprochen, dass das eigentliche Problem nicht so sehr in den Algorithmen oder Technik ist, die da angewendet werden, sondern in der Art und Weise, wie das Ganze verwendet wird. Was wäre denn sozusagen eine Wunschvorstellung, wie das Ganze ablaufen könnte? Also was wäre denn etwas, wo man dann sagen muss, okay, dann müssen wir keine Sorgen mehr machen?
Lass mich so anfangen. Zur Wunschvorstellung komme ich am Schluss. Also ich finde, dieses ganze Skandalon des Snowden-Skandals, das wurde von vielen Medien und auch von vielen Leuten in der Netzgemeinde so geflamed, dass jetzt die Privatheit abgeschafft wäre und wir müssten jetzt über das Private neu reden und so weiter. Und ich finde eigentlich geht es genau in die falsche Richtung. Wir müssen eigentlich mehr über das Geheime reden. Wir müssen eigentlich darüber reden, was geheim ist in dieser Gesellschaft und was wir als geheim akzeptieren in einer demokratischen Gesellschaft und was nicht. Also ist es legitim zu sagen, es gibt Dinge, die werden nur in zehn oder werden nur ganz wenigen Parlamentariern in einem Gezählengremium sozusagen dargelegt mit Rückfragemöglichkeiten und sonst darf das keiner wissen.
Also um es konkret zu machen, zu sagen, du redest jetzt davon, dass diese Geheimdienste, die diese ganze Überwachung veranstalten, auch von irgendjemanden kontrolliert werden?
Ja und wir wissen nicht, nach welcher Logik sie funktionieren, weil eben die Logik der Geheimdienste ist eben etwas, das aus ihrer Logik heraus schützenswert ist, geschützt werden muss. Deswegen ist natürlich Snowden auch das große, was ganz schlimm ist für die, weil er deren Logik veröffentlicht hat. Und wir müssen glaube ich darüber reden, also wie viel Geheimhaltung können wir akzeptieren? Wo ist Geheimhaltung sinnvoll, wo ist sie nicht sinnvoll? Und ich finde darüber wird viel zu wenig gesprochen.
Aber also heißt es zu sagen, heißt es umgedreht, dass du schon sagst, okay, damit das alles, was wir im Netz machen, irgendwie analysiert wird, damit müssen wir einfach leben. Und wir brauchen jetzt sozusagen eine gesellschaftliche oder politische Regelung, wie die Leute damit umgehen. Vor allen Dingen die Leute, die eigentlich dafür bezahlt werden, uns zur schützen vor Gefahren.
Nein, ich finde, wir müssen gar nicht damit leben, dass alles analysiert wird, was wir tun. Ich finde, wir müssen das einfach regeln und wir müssen es bestrafen, wenn jemand gegen diese Regeln verströst. Also ich glaube, sonst geht man Rechtsstaat auf.
Ich glaube, man muss auch ganz grundsätzlich das Konzept Geheimdienst infrage stellen an der Stelle. Es ist ja so, dass trotz dieser ganzen Überwachung, trotz dieser milliardenteuren Technik, zum Beispiel die NSA einfach nicht mitbekommen hat, dass da gerade in Nordafrika eine Revolution losgegangen ist. Als das da losging in Tunesien, das haben die erfahren, haltet euch fest, auf Twitter. Die geschätzte 90% der Erkenntnisse, der Geheimdienste, wenn nicht mehr, kommen aus öffentlichen Quellen. Also sogenannte Open-Source-Intelligence, OSINT ist der Fachbegriff bei denen. Die lesen einfach die Zeitung, wie jeder andere Mensch auch. Und natürlich braucht man, also wenn man sich jetzt mal in die Rolle eines Staates hineinversetzt, muss man wissen, was auf der Welt passiert, zweifels ohne. Aber es ist viel, viel sinnvoller, da einfach Leute einzustellen, die sich mit den verschiedenen Kulturen beschäftigt haben, die die Sprachen sprechen, die irgendwie wissen, was da losgeht, die da korrespondieren, hier vielleicht auch leben, die Zeitungen da lesen und diese Informationen einfach sinnvoll aufzubereiten, um gesellschaftliche Strömungen zu erkennen und das in, also das, was Intelligenz genannt wird, umzusetzen, nämlich eine Information für eine Regierung, die dazu führt, dass man sinnvoll auf der Basisentscheidung treffen kann. Dazu braucht man diesen ganzen Schlapphutkram einfach nicht. Zu 90 Prozent kommt die interessante Information da eh nicht daher, sondern einfach dadurch, dass man Leute fürs Denken bezahlt.
Das heißt sozusagen, die komplette Lösung ist politisch, die wir sozusagen anstreben. Das heißt aber auch, also Worst-Case-Szenarien, die machen einfach so weiter wie bisher, nur sozusagen, dass wir noch weniger davon mitkriegen. Es gibt bei der ganzen Technologie, der Auswertungsalgorithmen, eigentlich keine Art und Weise, wie man sich dazuverlässig vorwähren kann. Weil selbst wenn wir alle Inhalte verschlüsseln, können diese ganzen Sachen auch über die Metadaten funktionieren, wie wir heute auch gelernt haben, wieder gelernt haben.
Ja, also natürlich kann man auch versuchen, Metadaten zu verschleiern, indem man zum Beispiel regelmäßig sein Telefon mit seinen Freunden tauscht. Da gibt es eine Geschichte über einen Sprengstoff-Experten, der Hamas, der irgendwann seinen Kopf verloren hat, weil sein Telefon explodiert ist. Und da gab es so einen Onkel, der hat dann mal ein Geschenk bekommen. Und es war bekannt, dass der also regelmäßig seine Telefone tauscht und einfach rein statistisch irgendwann dieses Telefon in der Hand haben wird. Und dann haben sie einfach bloß diese eine Nummer überwacht und gewartet, bis er dran war und dann auf den Knopf gedrückt und dann sind irgendwie ihre Ohren geflogen. Also auch das hat seine Grenzen mit dem regelmäßig Telefonen tauschen. Technisch ist das Problem nicht zu lösen. Man kann den Leuten das Leben schwer machen. Man kann anfangen, alles zu verschlüsseln. Das ist auch das, was gerade passiert, dass viele Firmen ihre Webseiten komplett verschlüsseln, dass wenigstens dieses irgendwie auf den Knopfdruck alle Inhalte auswerten weggeht. Aber letzten Endes kann die Lösung eine politische Lösung sein.
Jetzt noch die Frage an euch beide, Joachim und Simon, ihr arbeitet ja an diesen Sachen. Der eine sagen wissenschaftlich, der andere sagen praktisch mit den Händen. Das fühlst du schon wieder in den Kopf, warum?
Ich finde, die Grenzen sind da glaube ich sehr fließend. Ich finde, total relevante Forschung findet außerhalb der Wissenschaft statt. Gleichzeitig sind wir ganz angewiesen auf solche Sachen, die er entwickelt hat. Die Grenzen sind da sehr fließend, finde ich.
Okay, die Frage an euch beide, was ihr an Erkenntnissen gewinnt oder an Maschinen baut, die so sagen, analysen können, kann natürlich dann auch wiederum gebraucht werden von Leuten, die diese Analysen machen, die wir eigentlich nicht wollen. Muss man sich mit dieser Frage auch beschäftigen, dass man da möglicherweise an Sachen mitbaut, die missbraucht werden können?
Also ganz ehrlich, bei mir überwiegt, dass die positiven Einsatzmöglichkeiten der Software, wir haben eigentlich ausschließlich über Negativsachen gesprochen, wo so eine Software eingesetzt wird. Es gibt aber, ich würde sagen, wesentlich mehr Einsatzgebiete, wo diese Dinge eingesetzt werden, um, ja ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen, Gutes zu tun. Aber zum Beispiel kann man auch so einen Twitter-Stream analysieren, um bestimmte Entscheidungen zu treffen im Katastrophenschutz, in der Katastrophenhilfe. Wo werden gerade im Moment Sandsäcke benötigt? Diese Informationen kommen ganz, ganz oft über solche Social-Media-Kanäle und dahingehend gibt es auch sehr viel Forschung. Diese Daten müssen auch sehr, sehr schnell in sehr großen Mengen analysiert werden, um anderen Menschen zu helfen. Das heißt also nicht, dass wir diese Software nicht nur bauen, damit wir jemanden überwachen können. Das ist eigentlich eher so ein Seiteneffekt des Ganzen.
Wie ist es bei den Linguisten? Müssen sie sich auch mit sowas beschäftigen? Was sagen die dazu?
Klar, also ich sehe das aber ganz genauso. Ich sehe natürlich, dass bei Google natürlich Sachen in der Forschung passieren, die ganz weit vorne sind. Aber natürlich ist uns auch klar, dass von Google beispielsweise keine kritische Forschung zu erwarten ist im Sinne von wir zeigen auch, was nicht geht oder wo Probleme sind oder wir machen auch eine gesellschaftskritische Forschung oder sowas. Und ich finde, deswegen ist es auch wichtig, dass wir uns an Universitäten mit diesen Dingen kritisch auseinandersetzen und auch sozusagen weil wir die letzten sind, die auch tatsächlich unabhängig sagen können, funktioniert oder funktioniert nicht oder hier ist ein Einsatzbereich, der nicht favorisierbar ist. Also ich finde das ganz wichtig, dass man das tut. Und natürlich ist jede Algorithmenkritik auch dazu geeignet, Algorithmen besser zu machen. Aber davor ist man nicht gefeit.
Also meines Erachtens ist die Grenze da überschritten, wo die Forschung dann geheim gehalten wird. Also gerade im Bereich der Linguistik, gerade in Deutschland sind zehn Jahre Forschung passiert, die komplett in den Tresoren verschwunden sind, die komplett beim BND gelandet sind. Also es gibt das Gerücht, dass ein ernstzunehmender Teil der Analysekapazität der NSA technisch vom BND kommt, was Sprachanalyse angeht, und das wurde an deutschen Universitäten mit unseren Steuergeldern entwickelt und dann der Öffentlichkeit nicht zur Verfügung gestellt. Und das halte ich für ein großes Problem, Dual-Use wird man immer haben, egal welche Forschung man macht.
Was wird uns denn in Zukunft an Analysefähigkeiten noch erwarten? Gibt da so einen kleinen Blick in die Kristallkugel? Werden da noch vielleicht neue Sachen mit rein verknüpft, oder wird alles noch größer, schneller und schöner?
Auf jeden Fall, es wird auf jeden Fall größer, schneller und schöner. Das ist natürlich auch von Interesse für sehr viele Firmen, für sehr viele Menschen, die da auch sehr viel Kohle reinstecken können. Aber auch natürlich, wir wollen uns auch weiterentwickeln. Das ist natürlich für mich steht zumindest die technische Herausforderung hier im Vordergrund. Und ich glaube nicht, dass wir schon sehr weit aus der Steinzeit raus sind, was das betrifft.
Also ich freue mich schon sehr auf funktionierende automatische Übersetzungssysteme. Also Google Translate gibt einem so ein bisschen den Vorgeschmack davon, was alles gehen könnte, wenn es gut funktionieren würde. Ich denke, in zehn Jahren sind wir da einfach so weit. Und ich glaube, das wird schon Konsequenzen für das Leben auf dem Planeten haben, wenn die Sprachbarrieren einfach fallen zwischen den Menschen weltweit.
Ein Babelfisch in unserem Ohr. Joachim, du hast ja gesagt, man weiß ja mal nicht, was also schon was der Gesagte mit dem Text möglicherweise gemeint hat. Gibt es da sozusagen schon Forschungsansätze, dass man sagt, okay, dass man über Video und gesprochen Sprache und so, dass man vielleicht tatsächlich das, also Inhalt analysieren kann?
Also, man kann denke ich viel machen, das hängt einfach von unserem Begriff von Inhalt ab wiederum. Ich weiß, es tut mir leid, wenn ich da so ein bisschen rumwabere, aber ich glaube, die Entwicklung geht eher so dahin, dass man Gespräche, also komplexe Interaktionen, also wir gucken uns jetzt immer Texte an, aber eigentlich sind es ja Interaktionen, dass man da zunächst mal in die Breite geht, dass man ganze Diskurse, Debatten und ähnliches, die aufeinander bezogen sind, viel stärker mit in den Blick nimmt, aber natürlich auch gesprochene Sprache, dass man da auch weitere Daten mit einem Beziel als nur das gesprochene Wort automatisch verfügbar macht, sondern natürlich geschieht ja auch schon Blicke, Gesten und ähnliches, dass die systematisch lesbar werden. Solche Sachen, glaube ich, werden unser Verständnis von dem, wie gesellschaftliche Bedeutung im Gespräch produziert wird, revolutionieren.
Also und die Vorgehensweise ist dabei immer dieselbe, sagen wir. Man bringt dem Computer bei, bestimmte Teile unserer Kommunikation zu katalogisieren und dann sozusagen Relationen zwischen Einzelteilen herzustellen.
Also wenn wir auf dem Stand bleiben, auf dem wir sind ja, aber ich hoffe, die KI macht auch noch was.
Okay, das wäre dann möglicherweise ein anderes Chaosradio, das ich an dieser Stelle auch beschließen möchte. Vielen Dank an Anna Biselli, die hier noch bei uns war. Und auf Wiedersehen, Andreas Bogk.
Schönen guten Abend.
Simon Willnauer. Vielen Dank. Und Joachim Scharloth.
Schönen Abend noch.
Das ist glaube ich das erste Chaosradio, das ich mir persönlich noch einmal anhören muss, weil es da ein paar erstaunliche Wendungen gab. Ich hoffe, ihr hattet Spaß, wenn ihr noch Fragen habt. Könnt ihr die gerne loswerden. Ihr könnt zum Beispiel an chaosradio.ccc.de schreiben. Ihr könnt auf Fritz.de den Podcast hören. Der wird später auch nochmal auf chaosradio.ccc.de erscheinen. Und Simon, wollt ihr noch was sagen?
Ja, ich wollte nur nochmal verdeutlichen, dass egal, was man damit machen will, je mehr Daten, desto besser.
Ah ja, je mehr Daten, desto besser. Liebe Leute, ich verabschiede mich. Ich übergebe an Flo Heiler. Der wird euch im Night Flight mit Punk-Musik bewerfen. Und mir bleibt nur noch ein zu sagen. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Lasst ihr nicht überwachen. Und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.